is no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey you guys happy friday it is friday
isn't it yeah
yeah i'm so
i'm so not knowing what day it is
show's going to be about unit 731 if you
guys don't know what that is
it was a uh japanese world war ii
uh experimental
unit that experimented on humans
this is gonna get dark y'all biological
chemical warfare radiological warfare
and uh i think that's about it
yeah yeah
this is bad yeah
did a lot of [ __ ] to uh chinese
prisoners and some american prisoners
not even prisoners just people they like
snatched from villages and stuff hey
you're right yeah we need an experiment
you were chinese i think they were in
chinese most of them there were like
some other ones too might have gotten
some koreans in there yeah sure but uh
it's been a long time since i've read
about it but uh it was pretty uh
pretty wild from this program
all those damn secret weapons you saw
that they were trying to destroy
godzilla with came from this program
probably that is not a lie
remember the ray gun they kept [ __ ]
shooting godzilla with
yeah they were trying to figure that out
the microwave weapon and yet when when
we talk about some of the horrible
horrible experiments and this is
something that came out later it's just
like a lot of the um a lot of the
information that they came up with was
like not super useful
um so i feel like a lot of the
experiments they were doing were just
because they were [ __ ] up sociopaths
oh yeah and they were just you know it
was like some joseph mengele [ __ ] but
like not
maybe even worse than that i don't know
it didn't evidently yield a whole lot no
that's what i'm saying so i think and i
think a lot of the experiments that they
did like
i can't even think of what they would
use as a cover story to say like why
we're doing this experiment so it's like
we just wanted to do it science man
science because we're psychos yeah
science pretty much that's that's kind
of it if the reports are accurate i mean
you know a lot of the [ __ ] we got
destroyed but uh they're pretty sure
they know they were working with cyber
magnet cycle of magnetrons and just
bombarding dudes with microwaves
um
some of that experiment exists but if
you ever see uh godzilla gojira whenever
they show the [ __ ]
vehicles pulling up the tr the the
trucks with the trailers behind it and
then they got the tube with the damn
radar dish on it they pointed godzilla
the beam comes out and kills them that's
what they were trying to make
actually we're trying to make that
spoiler alert they did not
yeah the japanese the japanese were uh
the americans were focusing on the
atomic bombs the the japanese were
focusing on a death rate
yeah death rate
yeah which would align the whole island
who wouldn't want a death ray if you
could invent one we're going to line the
coastline of all the damn the whole
island with death rays and zap those
incoming [ __ ] americans as they were
coming in pew pew pew
yeah which sounds good but uh
they know what they were talking a lot
of things sound good but you know
they didn't understand the energy
demands
for something like that that's what i'm
saying and like you can think up a lot
of [ __ ] can you actually do it in a
practical fashion
nuclear power power that made death rays
might as well just drop atomic bombs on
them much easier much easier yeah that's
the thing it's just kind of like i'm
going to try like hell because i've been
reading about this and watching
documentaries and [ __ ] i'm going to try
like hell
i don't know this is this is one of
those topics that it's like i feel bad
like when we go off on sidetracks and
we're like funny and stuff because this
[ __ ] is just like
it's just it's like so terrible and it's
like so soul crushing but
i'm kind kind of like slightly mollified
by the fact that both time suck and last
podcast on the left
managed to do shows about this that were
horrific and also
entertaining and funny at the same time
without being without it like making fun
of it you know what i'm saying so it is
like possible to do but this is like
pretty [ __ ] grim i'm just telling you
right yeah it's weird that this happened
and then this you know once the allies
took over
japan as an occupation force
oh they just brushed all this under the
rug
yeah it seemed like a lot of people
didn't even really know about it until
what like the 1950s and even then like i
feel like a lot of people it wasn't like
widespread knowledge yeah
a lot of the [ __ ] that they did it
wasn't as
it wasn't the vast amount of people as
it was the holocaust but i think a lot
of it was looking a lot worse than a
holocaust a certain extent
um
and they never the japanese never really
got punished for it not really um the us
at least didn't we'll get into that the
soviets did they had a trial but um yeah
even then it's they got off pretty late
yeah people forget about the japanese i
think the idea i think the reason why
they never really had any war crimes uh
tribunals around this is because
the japanese when they surrendered they
were real obedient they just obeyed
whatever the emperor said
and the emperors told him to retreat and
to be good and not to resist and just go
back to work and they did that and i
think the last thing the the american
forces wanted was to start hunting down
war criminals inside there
because that would have uh disrupted the
harmony that was inside japan
i think they had a lot to do with the
politics
well they just kind of did whatever they
were told to do they weren't
some would say they weren't real
responsible for what they did they were
you know hey you cut that woman's head
off yes sir they would just do it
because that was just the culture that
they had another thing too was that the
us
loki wanted the research just to see
well not so much
but that was germans too yeah well they
wanted it because they were kind of like
well we we kind of want it because we
can't do human experimentation but we
also want it because we don't want the
soviets getting hold of it just in case
there's like some cool [ __ ] in there
yeah um
so you know so there was that so they're
like well we'll give them ladies
if they if they cough up the information
all that nuremberg work trial stuff yeah
that's all fine and dandy but there was
a lot of hypocrisy in it too because uh
we were doing not that type of war
crimes but other types of war crimes
like bombing whole [ __ ] cities
burning up children and [ __ ]
because that was just the state of the
art technology at the time had we lost
we would have [ __ ] been in war crimes
tribunals also well sure there was a lot
of
hypocrisy
in the aftermath of war you bastards you
were bad so you're going to go to jail
yeah well everybody does [ __ ] yeah
everybody was doing although to be
honest
stuff like that stuff like the holocaust
stuff like unit 731 this stuff is way
beyond the [ __ ] pain way beyond the
veil
although i must say beyond the pale
beyond the pill were the russians
and they and they were our allies
and uh they basically just raped and
burned their way all through europe and
in into berlin there were even russian
military female witnesses there just
said it was just an army of gang rapists
they were just murdering german women
and stuff they were [ __ ] brutal
um
they just and they ever
every female from like eight to eighty
they just [ __ ] raped them and they'd
find big piles of dead women and [ __ ]
and parts of berlin
the germans were surrendering to the
americans and the americans would go no
you guys you got ammo left go kill some
russians before you surrender then come
back look what they're doing to their
women they were showing photographs
because we were going to turn on the
russians anyway the russians the
americans going to turn on each other in
any minute they were bad too
as soon as the war was over cold war
began
yeah but uh when it came to just
ultimate [ __ ] brutality
the russians were [ __ ] terrible
and they were our allies so
it gets back to the damn so like i said
basically everyone sucks yeah
yeah
we were the less
although i i will say i have never done
any war games so
i would say united states and you know
america was the least of all the suck
had the least suckatude
um
maybe even the italians they were they
they weren't real known for [ __ ] a
lot of barbarism but uh no america did a
lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] too we machine
gunned prisoners and stuff german
prisoners
killed dudes and did stuff but we it was
all just depending on where you were at
the war at any given time
you know what i mean you could it was
chaos
like you know that's the thing i mean i
feel like in that in that kind of i'm
not excusing it obviously but it's just
kind of like during that thing like you
would get away with [ __ ] that obviously
you wouldn't get away with yeah a bunch
of germans would surrender and [ __ ]
you know and they'd be all cool with
them you know this is right after the
d-day invasions the landing and uh
just out they'd be out there smoking
cigarettes with the germans and [ __ ] and
one dude to just walk up to a [ __ ]
german [ __ ] machine gun him and then
the
american guy would they pile on why'd
you do that those [ __ ] killed
my brother you know
that's just you know what are you gonna
do
yeah that's the thing it's just yeah
it's [ __ ] up and that did happen that
was an actual thing that was in uh that
was in the 506th
uh somewhere else in the theater the
dude just got a letter the day before
that that he had died in some kind of an
attack
fighting the russians but you know he
got the letter from home that his
brother had been killed by and uh he
just wanted to kill a german
yeah you did that [ __ ] today you get in
serious trouble but back in those days
they just said well it's under the
stress of war and they let a lot of [ __ ]
slide back yeah and then there was time
i think it's not good to let [ __ ] like
that slide
well there's no laws there's not this is
not happening inside of civilization the
countries are just totally buckled and
crushed now they did
if some [ __ ] was just beyond the pale
you know what i mean like some kind of
[ __ ] sexual crime against a civilian
who's not even not even in on an enemy
side the americans would punish you for
that
um
you know
uh button
no sometimes that random [ __ ] they let
it slide it was it's better to put that
dude back into service because everybody
was dying millions of people were dying
you know it wasn't a lot of sanity i
think mental health wasn't what it was
today back then
imagine if you saw basically if it would
probably
that that period and 731 comes from that
period from the point of view the people
that were living at that time this was
the apocalypse they could not imagine a
world after it
not as you know it
so
and to be honest i'm surprised anybody
that came out of that that saw any of
this stuff firsthand like was able to
get past that and like be normal again
whole cities were just reduced to rub
rubble i mean i can't imagine like
living through something or seeing some
of this [ __ ] like that we're gonna talk
about today like just seeing that
firsthand that would like yeah one of
the worst things america did you know
and for use you guys don't know who i am
i'm a veteran the us army first in the
506 infantry which is an airborne unit
first three two seven recon [ __ ] with
tiger force a little [ __ ] recompense
you know i served the empire and back
when the empire was strong okay
um
but yeah bad [ __ ] happened and uh
even during world war ii it was another
time
example like i think probably the worst
thing america ever did was we bombed i
think it was the 63 japanese cities most
of it was fire bombs it was much worse
than the hiroshima attack just
what they did to
tokyo they just burned it burned it to
the [ __ ] ground
and uh witnesses survived it who were on
those bomber crews they just said their
heads would be spinning you said you
could smell the burning flesh after they
were going through those different
bombing runs of all those people down
there burning
and
those waste gunners would look out the
side of the waist and look down in the
[ __ ] burning city and they could just
think that they could hear nothing but
screams but they were way up high
there's no way there could have been
screams but they
they thought they could hear well yes
i can understand that you could smell
burning hair and burning flesh and stuff
and in those [ __ ] unpressurized
bombers up there it was horrible so it
was like looking over the sea a sea of
flames like looking into hell
because tokyo burned
like i said i can't [ __ ] imagine yeah
well because like i said you know for
the past couple days that i've been like
watching documentaries about this and
like reading about it and stuff like
that it's just kind of like i'm trying
to put myself into the mindset
of somebody that was just going about
their daily life being a farmer or
whatever and then they just get picked
up by this [ __ ] unit
and taken to a play
just like the [ __ ] they did there was
just like [ __ ] unspeakable yeah you
know what i mean and it's just kind of
like i can't imagine that being like the
last day or two of your life like going
through that kind of [ __ ] it must have
been [ __ ] horrifying the value of
human life during world war ii in the
theaters of the operation was [ __ ]
very low very very very very cheap yeah
[ __ ] yeah a lot of people now that's
a setup for the show thank you we gotta
[ __ ] got a super chat twenty dollars
with that safety stop prop says uh
mentioned the men behind the sun yeah i
think that is uh about this actually is
it fictional movie or documentary i
can't remember thank you tb triggers
thank you very much just because i love
you guys oh thank you very much we love
you too okay so uh
now let's go ahead and [ __ ] get ready
how many people are in here let's give
them a little bit of news
we went and saw the new house today it
looks [ __ ] great we got the keys
got the keys i got uh
i got power turned on over there well it
was on we just haven't transferred
transferred it
and uh
gonna get the internet set up and um
we're probably going to start moving
down there monday
and uh we may
for that week for next week we might
take a break
well we'll see how it goes
i mean like i said i hear from us in
terms of live streaming or whatever we
have to see how much time that it that
we have
we're i'm going to see how much [ __ ] i
can get done tomorrow like as far as
packing because like i said my stuff
i don't have a lot of i'm not taking
most of this furniture
um that's in here at least most of it's
sorting through garage and storage yeah
and so bigger stuff like bed furniture
[ __ ] like that yeah so i don't know
we'll see we'll see so but like i said
refrigerator refrigerator oh yeah that's
right yeah and a bunch of generic two
generators and a bunch of window unit
air conditioners for emergency
you never throw an air conditioner away
in florida never hell no no
great to have generators too
well yeah the i mean and that one
generator's name yeah and then i got to
get the motorcycles down there i'll ride
two of them and then the little ct-70
will carry that in a car or something
yeah cause that's small enough to go on
my backseat probably yeah
but yeah we're you know like i said
priority is i want to get you know
internet's getting set up on monday
um so we're like going to i mean so
setting up my office is like top
priority yeah because that's kind of
like so i'm gonna try but like i said
i'm gonna if there's like interruptions
in some of the live streams like maybe
we have to skip a matinee live stream or
something like that
um i'll try and keep on doing the
the main show and maybe the side track
show but some of the matinees might i'm
going to try not to but we'll see how it
goes because like i said you can always
drop an update inside the inside the
stream yeah yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying so because i want to get over
there and at least get the office
painted and the i got to get the
internet connected
yeah and get that [ __ ] going because we
can't they um they don't have we have a
tnt here right yeah they have att they
don't have a t over there um because
it's a little bit out so i gotta get
wireless you have to get centurylink and
i gotta see if a lan cable
can be run up to the office
or wherever thank you green spark
hi and happy friday long time lurker
congrats on the move thank you very much
thank you
yeah i'm excited about it
i was so excited to see that whole top
floor i'm like oh my god
it's huge and there's so much room and
it's just kind of like there's so many
rooms that we don't even know we're
going to do with all of the bottom floor
isn't that big it's weird because it's a
lot of its garage garage and
well the bottom floor is kind of big too
but like i mean the top floor the top
floor essentially has four bedrooms and
one big huge
long room that's like a living room
lounge it's like a second living room so
it's like man we have so much stuff like
i said i don't even know we're gonna
have an indoor gym in this one yeah i'm
gonna put the um
put my bench in there weight bench in
there probably gonna get jenny a um
uh exercise exercise bike
i've been wanting to get one for a while
i just haven't got around to it i think
there might be a room to get a squat
machine in there
yeah well i mean we'll see like i said
as long as
it's you know it's not a massive room
but it's big enough for it in this room
it's bigger than this room so
we'll put a few things in there yeah
that'll be nice and it'll be under it'll
be air conditioned yeah jenny wants to
paint one of the rooms though well i
want to paint the office and the
attached bathroom because the room that
i'm going to use as an office has a
bathroom like attached to it with a
little
makeup center and a little closet and
also it'll be nice you know what i might
do you know these floor lights that
we're using for lighting maybe i'll
mount them onto the ceiling over there
and run the wiring up on the ceiling
that way we're not stepping over lights
and cords
yeah we'll see we'll see how it goes i
mean you know they have a little thing
that you can mount them right yeah maybe
mounted to the ceiling yeah i thought
they could
then uh just use like push pins to mount
them cords but make sure they're out of
out of shot
october 8th says is it haunted how many
people have died in there i don't think
anyone's died in there it's not that old
12 years old
yeah it's probably the same age as this
one i mean maybe it's on it it's a house
like this one's just two stories yeah
it's just bigger than this one that's
all but it's like similar i think it was
built around the same time i'm kind of
happy to get out of here man they're
expanding this road they're building
around here this is straight up [ __ ]
suburbia now this used to be at the edge
of town in orlando this should be like
the edge of orlando now it's orlando
almost it feels like orlando it's
becoming suburban sprawl
well yeah out there this is 10 miles
away it's still kind of like it's it's
grown up i used to live out there too
but it's it's changed i mean you got
sushi restaurants and [ __ ] now
[Laughter]
you millennials with your avocado toast
restaurants avocado toast and sushi
restaurants they had a biker bar there
still no go to that damn biker bar
you can go to that bike i'm not going to
that biker bar yeah
i've had my fill of biker bars
from growing up right down there yeah
yeah go hang out with with yeah yeah
yeah
afternoon that's when it's in the real
bikers that's not the real drone
they're real hardcore yeah yeah yeah
they got some skinny ass [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] tube top swinging on that damn
pole was you too
no teeth on her and like half her teeth
so she how you doing baby
yeah give me some money
[Laughter]
tuck it right in here get that right in
there and this is
near the stretch marks yeah yeah
what's wrong with sushi tom tom actually
loves sushi no sushi is a side of jet i
love it but it's a sign of
gentrification well yeah all i'm saying
is like
this used to be the type of place where
it's like you'd have a gas station like
a a crab shack or a diner and that's
about it you know what i mean diner but
now they have a sushi place like
right up the street there's a sushi
place there's a
grocery store there's an ice cream
parlor there's a bar and grill there's
all kinds of stuff yeah like a nice one
and there's an amc theater and all that
yeah yeah so
it's a normal place now but it used to
be just horse farms yeah so there was
like nothing around yeah for horse farms
and there are a lot of high-end houses
but they're all kind of like hidden
rich people living up in there they're
not even from here like nobody wants
yeah they don't even look they're not
even from here they're from other states
and [ __ ] california and new york and
stuff oscar says very happy to hear of
the good fortune bestowed upon you two
with the major house upgrade yeah i know
i was very excited because this was
actually the first time we had seen it
inside
in person like we've seen pictures of it
yeah the only thing the only thing we
don't know is the damn energy costs
well we'll see keeping that [ __ ] air
conditioned yeah we've never lived in a
two story so i'm not really sure i mean
i have a long time ago but i wouldn't
see you gotta live in a place like three
or four years before they can get your
average power consumption and then they
can average it out to a monthly bill
and you see when it's averaged out to a
monthly expense it's a lot easier but
here in florida
when they hit you just monthly you're
okay until summer comes then all of a
sudden it's a thousand dollar a month
energy right it's kind of like in the
winter it's kind of like nothing and
yeah it's like nothing in a thousand
bucks and then it's like three times
right when you can at when you can
average it out then it's only you know
maybe 300
200 depends 250.
so yeah we just got to see
it'll be good
i mean like i said i'm excited yeah
after it was 80 degrees in there when we
went in there and it didn't feel that
hot 80 degrees would [ __ ] kill you in
this house i don't know why it just when
that thermostat says 80. it feels like
it's 90 in here it does yeah but 80 in
there felt quite good i don't know yeah
i didn't really notice it being like
warm or anything yeah i think they had
the thermostat on 79.79
yeah and it wasn't
i didn't notice it being like all of
that i felt like it fails in here right
now and it's it's uh 72. yeah so there
you go yeah so like i said maybe it's
more energy efficient energy efficient
something something about maybe about
the the flow of the air because it has
that big central open thing that's yours
maybe airflow might be better i think i
was actually like um pleasantly
surprised i thought it was like i
thought it was beautiful inside yeah i
just it was really nice and it looked
like it was in really good shape yeah
you know what i mean like it looked like
it had really been taken care of it's
pretty it was pretty yeah i thought
especially the upstairs i think guys are
like out there and being out there
on the edge of the city [ __ ] on the
engine edge of town it's bear country
it is bears and animals and [ __ ]
and uh being out there i could get back
to riding motorcycles riding a
motorcycle isn't very fun around here
there's too much traffic right now
didn't used to be like that but then
well yeah like i said it used to be kind
of rural out here but not anymore like i
said just the [ __ ] they blocked off the
road we left to go up to the house today
and then we got part of the way and they
had blocked the road off because they
were like widening it or re-grading it
or something uh david i got your uh
shirt done man it's right over here yeah
cause didn't you say you wanted a shirt
for your friend i think i sent you a
message that said do you want me to just
send it to your regular address because
i'm pretty sure i have that
um but if you don't let me know
and i'll
mail it i mean maybe we can mail it
tomorrow or sunday
i'm trying to think like when yeah see
there you go
it's got it in fat boy size
yeah put 13.
you're so nice yeah what is what it is
three xl [ __ ] that's bad boy size
it's four four xl
i think that was the last one i that i
had for xl3xl look at that i think it
was three xl no it's four is it can you
read no no i don't can't read it
[Laughter]
that bigger image looks a lot better on
these bigger shirts yeah i'm glad we did
a bigger one yeah i still got to do this
other like the cannon and stuff like
that holy crap yeah cannon and ocp are
on the way he says yeah my normal
address will work okay awesome all right
so that's all i need to know so if we
have time we will try to mail it this
weekend i gotta run up to the
post office didn't you say that there
was a post office much closer to the new
house yeah okay that's good because we
which is dumb because now we're like
almost in the middle of like suburbia
now but the post office is like [ __ ]
five miles you gotta fight traffic to
get to it and it's like yeah it's a pain
in the house to get to but it's like so
yeah that's that's actually uh quite
cool yeah good question david goes
speaking of tube tops where's sandra
where is sucking tan yeah maybe she's
got something else to do it's friday
night
stop prop says just do what you have to
do post an update as things progress
that's what we'll do like i said i'll
try
not to like i'll try to keep up the
regular schedule
but if we have to skip a couple like
movie review live streams then maybe we
will like depending because we might not
have time to like watch a movie or
you know what i mean
because actually we were going to go to
a movie yesterday and we didn't have
time i got a uh
firearms related question this is from
prepper pov tom do you see an issue with
keeping a silencer on a gun 24 7 for a
home defense rig the only problem i have
with silencers is that silencers do not
exist there are only sound suppressors
that [ __ ] is never silent okay
you suppress a nine millimeter and use
subsonic ammunition it will sound like
an unsuppressed 22 in general
a suppressed
22 long rifle pistol
done right sounds about like a bb gun
you can hear the bullet impact
can't suppress any kind of ultrasonic
rifle none of that you can suppress
subsonic 300 uh what is it what's it
called
[ __ ] that went to 300
[ __ ] i forgot the name of the down
cartridge what's that new cartridge
where you can uh convert an ar upper to
30 caliber you'll know what i'm talking
about i think it's called 300 300
whisper somewhere
anyway um
i'm running the subsonic once those
sound about like a
it's not about
about like a 38 special kind of
um as long as you got it registered
and you can legally possess that
suppressor
you can keep you can put that suppressor
on a pistol and use it for home defense
the main the biggest if you've ever
[ __ ] with suppression
for me
the big the best advantage to
suppression with pistols is that it
makes a pistol [ __ ] real easy to fire
it's very mild
pussycat type [ __ ] if you've got it
tuned right if it's the right ammunition
it's the right
operating springs and everything it's
all
good
they're just real sweet to shoot really
easy to shoot
and of course you don't need
you don't need a bunch of hearing
protection
i mean they're still loud but they don't
really ring your bell in an enclosed
area as much
and
they're just kind of sweet so
if you're in a jurisdiction that allows
them and you can legally possess it then
yeah you can use it for a home defense
rig but
why would you use the pistol for home
defense i mean
pistols are really for concealment
what would be better is like
a nine millimeter converted ar-15 with
that cmmg
rotating bolt was that what it kind of
like delayed rotating bolt system from
cmmg
but a suppressor on that
because you know anything with the butt
stock's easier to deal with and if
that's suppressed
with 147
with 147 subsonic ammunition it'd be a
real pussycat be like a 22
a little more recoil but
not as much as uh the blowback versions
if you know what i'm talking about that
cmmg delayed blowback with the rotating
lugs it's real mild about like an mp5
that's all i'm saying about it
uh okay so i had a couple other shout
outs as well i don't think esther is
here unfortunately but i'll give her
another shout out next time we live
stream but she sent me some lovely
early birthday presents one of which is
this gorgeous necklace right here
look at how beautiful
she also sent me these awesome
earrings these were actually from my
amazon wishlist because i've been
wanting these for a really long time
because i love the green
look at how pretty i love this like
screen kind of stuff so thank you so
much esther that is so so awesome also i
love the little gift bag also
the last two games remember i said
that i had two more games that i
designed a long time ago but i hadn't
like ordered them yet so i finally got
the proof copies so this is my absinthe
themed one
called the green hour and that's kind of
like
it's kind of like a thing where you it's
like a
you go around and you have to like
collect all the drink tokens from all
these different uh bars
from paris at around the time of you
know absinthe was like super popular
those were all like real clubs and stuff
this one i still have to like go through
and like do all the web graphics and
stuff for this which won't take that
long i'll probably i'll try to do that
this weekend and put it up for sale so
this one's not for sale yet but it will
be before the end of the weekend
this one is my ancient egypt one
right there so that's that one
and this
is the back that's what the board looks
like it's got like little mummies and
little corn it's like super cool and fun
and uh yeah this one actually is up for
sale
but the absinthe one will be up for sale
before the end of the week and i think
that's all the ones that i had up there
i was so excited to finally get all of
those
because like i said you have to order a
proof copy before you're allowed to put
them up for sale so you can like look at
how they printed
um so i finally those are the last two
that i had to put up
yeah uh prepper 300 300 blackout you're
right i was thinking 300 whisperer that
was the first one that came out
but those are good cartridges too
but mostly for suppression or close
range type stuff kind of like an 8k
round but uh 300 blackout i think they
had a 240 grain load it was real heavy
real slow and it was quiet out of a
suppressor
but um
yeah
pistols always last ditch man you go to
pistol last if it's for home defense man
get carby
david june says how are you so talented
jenny i have no idea uh damn can i have
just a quarter of it it's a well
i don't know i don't even know so much
that it's just like
there's a million things that i want to
do and it's like there's just so much
and like i said nowadays that there's
like opportunity when i first found the
site like the game crafter and i was
like you mean i can design my own board
games holy [ __ ] i'm totally doing that
but
in a lot of ways it's bad because every
time i think of like a new
format it's like oh look i can design
t-shirts i can design board games i can
do this that and the other and it's like
so i want to do a million things and i
know i'm not gonna have time to do it
all so i don't have much focus but you
know
that's that's one of the things i have a
million things i want to do but i don't
like
i don't have the the discipline to just
focus on one thing that long you know
what i'm saying
i just can't bored of doing one thing
all right so our next cat escaped off
the second floor no can't it
man that cat didn't go far
i hope not
no it'll be back
oh please
tell me that it comes back
um it jumped it's on it's that cat's
fault jumped off the second floor
balcony well that's not making any
better does that
i just hope that there was grass a
grassy place where he could land
but um
no a cat can fall from quite far without
breaking a limb i know you're worried
about that cat's all right
it'll be back
i hope so i mean they usually do if it
runs from people then people won't be
able to grab it i'd walk around
call call him in the middle of the night
and see if you could hear her meow
i'm always like i'm always like so
worried about that hiding in the bushes
somewhere they're hiding underneath the
car
i mean that's what our cats do
that's why i don't worry as much about
them although i will worry about them
for a long time we move to the new place
because
it's going to be unfamiliar to them and
they're going to be like they're either
going to be scared or they're going to
be like man i'm going to check all this
[ __ ] out and they'll be wandering all
over the place and i don't really like
the sound of that they got a good sense
of direction they don't get lost very
easily
and honestly i kind of feel like lately
it just seems like they mostly just want
to sit on the porch or sit in the bushes
they like to sit in the bushes and like
watch people going by yeah you know what
i mean
um melanie murphy asks where can i get
the game uh at the game crafter i think
uh the link is usually in the
description box i think i usually put it
in there
but like i said the absinthe one is not
for sale yet because i haven't done the
web graphics but that won't take that
long i'm hoping to do it like this
weekend and have it up by monday but all
the other ones are up i have like a
whole [ __ ] ton of them
you know
um mr roboto said tom are you hard rock
today or classic rock
i don't like doing that [ __ ]
metal
metal and new wave and some old punk and
goth music and goth industrial and
good [ __ ] like that good [ __ ] like that
yeah classic stuff that's a classic rock
is what i listened to
when i was in high school [ __ ] as a
dishwasher [ __ ] washing dishes and
the cooks have the damn [ __ ] classic
raccoon listen to listen to [ __ ] bob
seger and [ __ ]
some of the [ __ ] was good though [ __ ]
you know uh uh
oh what's his name you know [ __ ]
southern man what does what's that do
his name [ __ ] young neil young yeah
i like neil young he's pretty good
it's like the george burns of rock and
roll
dude around forever
[ __ ] um
what else
that don't matter
doesn't matter
classic rock camp guy said do you have
to know a lot of egyptian lore to play
the game no it's like it's pretty uh
easy i think and pretty self-explanatory
yeah you can buy that where
the game crafter the game crafter like i
said i usually put the um
the link is usually in the description
link in the description
i mean my site my plugin
my store is called giallo games because
when i originally started designing
games they were all giallo based yeah
but then i started being like ooh i
could do a game like this and ooh i
could do a game like that so how do you
spell giallo
g-i-a-l-l-o
okay
it means yellow and attack yeah
people aren't sophisticated though i
don't know how to spell that you know i
would never find it tom thinks
everyone's a dummy yeah no
i'm a trade salesman i know that the
dumber that [ __ ] is the more it will
sell
the dumber it is more of a sale i'm not
worried about it i'm more i would have
made the name i'm more worried about
doing something that i like and enjoy
doing than giving a [ __ ] about what dumb
people think of it
i would have named the site [ __ ] big
titty games never forget it and every
dumbass can find it big titty games
sell a bunch of [ __ ] sell [ __ ] to dudes
yeah yeah bunch of crushed beer cans and
[ __ ]
it's my it's my fresh beer my crushed
beer can business yeah crushed beer cans
of [ __ ] but what fun would that that
would be just like having a regular job
that i that i hate yeah why would i want
to do that yeah well you have a high end
line and then you have your bread and
butter line see okay and the bread and
butter line's [ __ ] like down to the
lowest common denominator what why don't
you why don't you start a baby i can
help you to do it i could help you how
to do it i don't have time to do that
you have time you figure it out yeah you
do you can figure it out she's always
trying to get me to do something
well he's always trying to get me to do
so i'm like dude i already have like
three jobs what the hell else you're all
in here though
i know i need to get a laptop i need to
get a laptop i need to start people are
saying tom you need you can use this one
actually i don't use that one that much
i want a live stream though some people
are saying tom you need to have your own
chat you can live stream you can live
stream on that yeah yeah i think it'll
uh
won't [ __ ] up like last time we tried to
live stream on that well i don't know
but live streams well like i said work
crash we're moving so we'll see how it
goes but like i said i have that one
there if you i don't use that one yeah
so if you want to get that one so that's
tom you get up here do some stand up and
just [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] around and then
give your opinions on [ __ ] not comment
on on uh
on [ __ ] current events
and [ __ ] put forth my [ __ ]
hypothesis my predictions about how
everything's going to go
i'll just read the news i can read the
news
here's the thing
some of you guys listen to sausage
cracker i like sausage cracker i could
beat salty cracker when i'm really
worked up i could [ __ ] i would first
of all i could do that gig mine would be
different it'd be a lot different
although i [ __ ] i like his work
i would be even more audacious i'd i'd
be kicked off youtube quick
i'd have to put that [ __ ] up on [ __ ]
[ __ ] shoot or something what's the
other one [ __ ] odyssey i'd have to
stream that [ __ ] off of odyssey
well like i said if you could kick me
off youtube you are welcome to that uh
laptop if you would like to use it but
you're gonna have to like buy your own
camera and [ __ ] like that though yeah i
could do that that's no big deal i'd be
up there it would be mostly motivational
although actually you could probably use
that one and i could hook that one up
because i do actually do i actually do i
wouldn't use that one i actually do have
you got that one and never used it i
have another camera and i have another
microphone uh although i don't know if
that other yeti works or not
it's kind of like intermittent
you know we have all kind of like
no people did not walk out of our lives
forever she jumped in [ __ ] last
wednesday and [ __ ] yeah she was here
for a few minutes on wednesday yeah
she's busy she's doing something yeah
like every you know not everybody has
time to like sit around listen like yeah
pepper saying tell me to do it
well yeah like i said if you want to do
it titty games awesome that's right i'll
tell you man
dollywood a big boob theme park yeah see
there you go yeah i've never been to
dollywood no see
that would be really funny if they had
like a um a bunch of woody columns like
roller coasters that were all just like
going up and down boobs and stuff see
the thing is the thing is is that when
you're live streaming with two people
it's a lot easier because me and jenny
can play off of each other
live streaming alone i'd ha you guys
would have to be in the comment sections
really [ __ ] with me and i would have to
make a bunch of notes to make to keep me
on track kind of like what jenny does
and i would probably although look how
effective that is yeah
i probably would just uh go through the
like the news of the day and read the
dues i become like a like a funny
newscaster and then i'd make fun of
[ __ ] what people said and just [ __ ] i
just have to go with with the flow you
know but i could do it it'd probably be
funny
probably funny
well you talk about the apocalypse and
then they gotta give [ __ ] preppers
like yeah do it now they give apocalypse
apocalypse [ __ ] concepts of [ __ ]
how to survive the zombie apocalypse
even though the zombie apocalypse
concepts played out
but yeah yeah really everyone's coming
well a zombie is just a hungry person
you know i mean they don't have a job
help
[Laughter]
which is kind of a hollywood concept of
what civilizational collapse looks like
but that's not how it really looks like
it doesn't look like it doesn't actually
look like that
it's more like eastern europe during the
[ __ ] year right there it looks more
like eastern europe the breakup of the
soviet union that's what it actually
would look like i'm not worried about
zombies i got enough [ __ ] i gotta work
yeah i'm definitely not worried about
zombies yeah
dudes looking for jobs women trying to
[ __ ] pimp themselves out [ __ ]
going off to dubai to [ __ ] make money
that's what it would look like
sorry if you like if you hear banging
and stuff like that it's actually
thunder yeah it's storming outside yep
again it even says raining now on my at
the bottom of my little computer it's
just started doing that the other day i
didn't notice yeah it started telling me
the weather
on the little bottom thing
um all right so
now that we've been like yapping for
like 46 minutes it's time to start
showing so are we actually gonna start
talking about this [ __ ] yeah like i said
you um
scroll down let me see how many notes we
got
he has to see how many notes we got
that many that's a long show i mean some
of that's not like like i said i just
kind of read that's well i don't need
that but um
but that's kind of like um yeah zuma
okay it's not that much yeah okay it
just looks like a lot yeah it's like
doing that's enough for a show yeah
because sometimes she'll get enough
notes i'm gonna [ __ ] with her
sometimes she'll get enough notes to do
five shows and she's like we gotta put
all this on well i i would have been
able to do it if you hadn't like kept
going off on like hour long tangents
[Laughter]
we're just gonna have a good show jenny
shit's gonna be funny all right it's
gonna be good i mean it's not gonna be
funny
like shit's not funny but okay like war
trucks
all right i'm gonna but like i said last
podcast on the left did it and time suck
did it and they and the [ __ ] was still
funny okay but they were it was still
funny without like making fun of the
[ __ ] yeah one of the things like this is
war crimes yeah yeah one of the things
we're talking about is
don't get too wrapped up in the
sufferings of others all right because
this happened a long time ago and
everything happened a long time ago if
you wait around long enough
all kinds of bad [ __ ] happened in the
past you can't stop it you can't go back
there and [ __ ]
stop it i know
anything because it already happened
everything dies doesn't matter if you're
human or animal or insect everything
eventually dies and a lot of [ __ ] dies
in a bad way and you know what a lot of
times they die for nothing
you know and it's just and most things
die for nothing but the thing about it
though is that the whole the whole uh
concept of empathy yeah is that you can
understand yeah like yes i know i can't
go back and like make this
not to have happened even though that
would be awesome if i could do that yeah
but
i still put myself in the shoes
of the of those people because that's
like i said that's what empathy is yeah
but you can't you can't [ __ ] you can't
do that too much it'll drag you down
with it's just like the vampire when a
vampire sucking your blood they start to
die if you focus in on it you go down
with the person don't do that
because uh yeah but i don't want to be a
sociopath either
you're look those that's all terminology
that comes out of psychology and
psychology is more of an art form it's
or a philosophy it's not a science oh
here we go don't don't [ __ ] don't
judge yourself for for your own
survival traits you know i'm talking
about why these people are calling
psychopaths and sociopaths what it is
they're just trying to survive
and uh they survive at all costs that
was not the case in this
in this though this was a very
regimented
and they knew exactly what they were
doing and they all knew that it was bad
and wrong and that they would get in
trouble if they got caught from the very
beginning yeah but whoever ordered it
thought that it was going to be done for
the survival of the japanese nation and
by the war effort they all think that
ultimately will help them survive thrive
or or conquer which is the same thing
you're trying to get you're trying to
get secret weapons technology that will
allow you to win
even conan knew that [ __ ] winning is
really well what is what what is best in
life what is best in life conan winning
you know just win
if you win you have to worry about
anything
it's true
i i don't think that's the case oh no
that is exactly the case america wanted
they didn't have to worry about any of
those war crimes tribunals had they lost
they would have been in war crime kurt
lemay would have been a war criminal
instead he ended up being the uh the
founder of the air force
yeah yeah
well yeah i'm just that's right that's
what's the reality i was just saying
general i'm insane you kill enough
people you eventually get away with it
you power through it
you become unstoppable people fear you
and then you become the new authority
then no one can try you
and that's the world's been like that
that's just how it works sorry i just
thought of it's too bad victor's not
here because um i was thinking of eddie
izzard talking about
talking about people who killed 100
million people or something like that
he's like he's like once you get over a
certain amount people are almost just
kind of like yeah you killed 100 million
people you must get up very early in the
morning i can barely get down to the gym
well look at that
look at mouth mao zedong was the biggest
one of them all and [ __ ] he was never
considered a criminal he was considered
the [ __ ]
father of modern china he's a hero to
this day over there that [ __ ]
made hitler look like a schoolboy i mean
he killed a lot more like a lot more
like six times that
of his own people i mean the point that
he was making was that once it's over a
certain amount like you can't really
like a single human brain can't really
conceive of that anymore
yeah you know because it's not you know
our brains aren't really like uh you
know didn't really evolve to process
those yeah
stalin murdered a lot more than hitler
he lived a full life and probably
murdered his wife and got away with it
too the other one so no you're killing
out people all of a sudden you just
become a bad [ __ ] they're scared
of you
you die an old man in in in your sleep
peacefully
like you're a g oh yeah which well yeah
and the the thing that a lot that pisses
a lot of people off about unit 731 is
that
um a lot of the people involved in this
including the dude that started it um
ishii shiro ishii shiro
um
he pretty much got away with it
um you know
just went and lived a normal life in a
little normal street
at the end he didn't really have to
you know face the music for any of his
crimes even though like i said he seemed
from the beginning he seemed to know
exactly what he was doing david june
asking us a question where did you like
me yes or no oh that's yeah yeah
yeah no we don't like you dude
go ahead of course we like you
[Laughter]
that's like pretty funny though so it's
like all those little notes you used to
pass [ __ ]
all right so
some people at the beginning said they
didn't know what unit 731 was now i'm
not really entirely sure why unit 731 i
guess because it was the worst one but
um is the one that everybody
talks about because there was more than
one of these you know what i mean there
was several
um but for whatever reason this one was
is like the best known and like i said
it seems like
it's almost kind of like it almost went
down the memory hole for a little while
um because really nobody knew much about
it until probably the 50s and then i
feel like
even after that it wasn't like super
widely known it wasn't a thing where
like you know the german atrocities like
the holocaust and everything like that
was pretty much known immediately but
because a lot of the
evidence of this of unit 731 was
destroyed
um purposefully
and because it was kind of
hushed up because the americans gave
them
immunity
so it never really had like a big show
trial like the nuremberg trials or
anything like that so i kind of feel
like it even though in a lot of ways
it was equivalent to like the holocaust
in the you know in the sense of like the
brutality the savagery of it i think it
was worse it it might have been i mean
in terms of pure numbers probably not
but i don't think anybody knows how many
people died it was a lot just even just
the nastiness of it but yeah the
nastiness of it like i said because i've
seen estimates from you know first units
of not just unit 731 but just all the
other units during this time period i've
seen estimates from
200 000 people to like 600 000 people
but they're not entirely sure
and most of these people were
brutally and horribly and unimaginably
tortured like the way they were treated
was just
um
yeah and the reason why i'm saying is
worse than the holocaust you have to
look at first of all the numbers
involved in the method and the system
that the third reich had
on average
if you got sent to a work camp you died
of starvation but it didn't take long
months
they overworked you and underfed you
you were dead within about six months or
a year
but that's not how most of them most of
them uh weren't killed that way all
right most people that died in the
holocaust died in poland in the death
camps which is as soon as they got off
the train they walked in they were
gassed so it happened quickly
it wasn't like a this was what we're
talking about it's kind of long
prolonged
kind of depending on what you ended up
getting
yeah depending on what it was yeah and
that they did you now they did do
mangala and a lot of these other guys
they did have some uh some medical
experimentation camps yeah like i said
this is like mangle-ish it yeah they did
the germans did have some of that
but they weren't they weren't what the
germans were doing is that they they
weren't trying to develop biological
weapons this has made a big difference
okay really what the germans wanted to
know is how long did it would it take
for freezing water to kill you
that so they they did some of that you
know yes and there was a reason for that
they wanted to know how long they had
to search for somebody a downed pilot
out in the english channel
he didn't want to waste fuel on a dude
who would have died y'all now you've
been out there 10 hours he's dead that's
all they wanted to know the other one
was uh pressure and acceleration because
they were doing dealing with rocket
stuff they want to know about rockets
and jets did that unit 731 yeah well
they were working on jets and rockets
too the other people know that the
japanese had some badass rockets and
jets they were working on so they wanted
to know about pressurization with
[ __ ] air cabins and aircraft they
wanted to know what the effects
acceleration and deceleration were
you didn't want to be one of those lab
rats that meant they were going to
[ __ ] kill you in a pressure in a in a
decompression chamber or a compression
chamber
bad [ __ ] not a good idea yeah um
i'll put you on a rocket sled and stop
you boom [ __ ] watch your eyes pop out
about the front of your head [ __ ] up
your eyes
uh did a lot of bad [ __ ] um another one
that the germans did is uh they um
what was it they had the
most the germans were mostly just about
endurance tests they wanted to know
what the human body could and could not
endure
um they did or they were working on some
[ __ ] with uh
forced twin births
yeah they wanted it because basically
what they wanted is they wanted um they
wanted fertility drugs because
they wanted each german birth
to have like twins at least and that way
they could re reproduce their numbers a
lot faster the japanese weren't into
that japanese ladies you have to have
twins yeah
most of the japanese effort when it came
to uh this unit we're talking about
let's go 731 731 yes
was about bio warfare so they were going
to be testing disease diseases yeah bio
warfare but like i said some of the [ __ ]
they were doing
didn't really have anything to do with
that and seemed like they were just
doing it to be [ __ ] up and twisted
yeah biowarfare [ __ ] the testing for
that
long and torturous nasty stinky
terrible [ __ ] um
sadistic
then um
then they were trying to develop energy
weapons
so they did [ __ ] up [ __ ] ty do doubt
bombard him with [ __ ] certain kinds
of radiation see what it did to him yeah
in other words just microwave a
[ __ ] put it
i think a cyclo magnetron on that [ __ ]
and just [ __ ] zap him
see how long it took to cook him
yeah it's like i'm not
i don't like one i don't care if it's
wartime or not i don't want to be around
a person that could do that to another
person which is kind of like i don't
hate anybody that much and i hate a lot
of people i don't hate anybody that much
which is kind of strange because you
know that energy will kill a person
you know why do you have to know
why do you have to test it on a human
why don't you just put a chick in there
if it kills that chicken or a goat then
you know it will kill a human
see that's why i think that a lot of
this was maybe you need to go and you
could eat the chicken afterwards but you
could i wouldn't but i'm just saying
well that well that's what i'm saying i
just kind of feel like
that's why i think that a lot of this
was just being sadistic
for the sake of it
because some of the [ __ ]
you wouldn't really have to i mean some
of the [ __ ] that they did was like duh
super obvious or you could have done it
to an animal which is also not cool but
you know what i mean um better than
doing it to a human
the germans it was a little it was kind
of more understandable if you put
yourself in their shoes they had excess
people that they were trying to get rid
of they were going to kill those people
anyway so you might as well use them
so that's what gave them their moral
permission to do this well we're going
to kill this person anyway so put them
in there
yeah japanese the japanese didn't really
kind of look at it that way
they had food they didn't have to reduce
their population
it's just they just look he's chinese
put him in there that was
pretty much
but i guess just pick up this random
villager just like walking down the road
although maybe i could be wrong about it
because
part
if i remember correctly part of what the
what the japanese were saying is that is
that part of their war against china was
a war of annihilation they were just
going to annihilate as many chinese as
they could to make a homeland for
themselves so i guess that's probably
the same thing the germans were in we
got to vacate this area these are excess
people we're going to kill them anyway
put him in there and use him
and these are hardcore [ __ ] people
you know what i mean
that's the thinking we should maybe we
should do a show about the rape of nang
king as well yeah that was some more
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
although it's it's hard to to know
exactly what happened because a lot of
stuff
a lot of dudes a lot of japanese dudes
[ __ ] who were killed on that island
fighting came from the nanjing
mission
and usgis were finding photographs
on these troops of gang rapes and
murders of girls
and they didn't know what that was or
where it came from they didn't know
those were chinese girls they thought
they were other japanese girls they
couldn't understand what they were
saying
but no those dudes got their issue
i don't really have a lot of i mean the
average dude average japanese guy in
deer
deer in this
during this time really hadn't seen
combat
he was up on some island the marines
showed up they fought he got his ass
kicked he was hungry he hadn't been
refueled in a long time or fed in a
while that starvation was getting them
by the time he got to him
but a lot of those guys uh a lot of
their elite troops [ __ ] came out of
the [ __ ] the chinese theater they'd
done a lot of bad [ __ ] they were cruel
very cruel
you know they're not the japanese that
you know of to today
they were the imperial japanese were
big
mean according to uh the american
accounts
uh very disciplined very loyal very
professional soldiers but ruthless real
real ruthless and they were ruthless to
subordinates so they were mean to each
other there was kind of like a hierarchy
they were just general [ __ ] yeah
they don't make japanese dudes like that
anymore they all died in the war thank
[ __ ]
we don't need we don't need that
business come on
there's enough [ __ ] in the world as
it is
we don't need even more [ __ ] and
particularly i think [ __ ] is like
not even a strong enough word for the
people that pulled off this
this [ __ ] right here the average
japanese was fighting for his homeland
in a certain way fighting to create a
new homeland in china
he was fighting to keep americans
[ __ ] off of the island because they
were just going to rape all the japanese
women that's what they were told that's
they were doing the chinese women so
they had account they had reasons to
believe that
so that's why they were crashing their
airplanes on [ __ ] aircraft carrier
decks because they were just trying to
stop at all costs to protect their women
because we were headed towards the
japanese main island i understand why
they did it it was uh
just a different
wars like that can't happen anymore
that's why they don't
well like i said i i cannot imagine what
it must have been like to live through
that you know what i mean and and the
fact that people that so many people
lived through it and were sort of mainly
normal afterward that just blows my mind
because if i had seen that firsthand i
don't know if i'd have gotten over it
the atomic bomb stopped all these large
scale wars like this that's not possible
with the with atomic weaponry
yeah you can't amass any troops they
just get hit
that's true the war of the future will
all be what you call terrorists that's
the war of the future
like i said it's not great but
it's smaller scale small scale smaller
scale and low what what they call low
signature
the the the soldier of the future won't
even be wearing a uniform
because his camouflage will be the dress
be dressed like a civilian yeah yeah and
he'll have lawyers with him and
political parties with them you know to
just it'll be full spectrum
with guys with cameras and just you know
it's
warfare always changes don't believe
what they say on that damn [ __ ]
fallout video game war never change no
changes all the [ __ ] time when world
war one broke out the turks [ __ ]
showed up to battle on horseback with
curved scimitars here we go
somebody everyone's like what are you
even doing
[ __ ] biplanes showed up machine gun
them all from and they're like what the
[ __ ] this isn't fair this isn't warfare
just machine gun the ball they're like
welcome to the 20th century [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] changed
well that's terrible yeah
the war that's going on now is [ __ ]
very
low-key james bond [ __ ]
invisible stuff propaganda mind control
lies gaslighting
armies of lawyers
internet censorship [ __ ] changing of
the mind mind control as a person who
use guns to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
they're not very good at it you can kill
a dude he vanishes but it doesn't change
anybody's mind new ones appear they just
keep coming and coming look at
afghanistan
couldn't even beat cavemen
couldn't beat caveman because uh but the
reason why it worked in world war ii is
because there were wars of genocide they
just fought until they're just all dead
well you can't do that now people will
get mad if you do that
so yeah
people got less mad back then about it
which is well that's which is alarming
like i said but like you said it was
because
i mean technology the technology and
they didn't really i feel like they even
then didn't really have much of us the
same sense of like
lives being valuable
no no the old
when back in the back in that part of
the 20th century warfare was genocide
yeah it was genocide
our demand on the japanese was
unconditional surrender yeah go think
about that yeah think about what that
means
unconditional surrender that means you
surrender and we do whatever the [ __ ] we
want and you can't [ __ ] about it ah
that's not acceptable terms of surrender
so they just kept fighting and fighting
and fighting and fighting and fighting
and fighting until they go oh okay
atomic bombs there oh okay and they had
no idea what we were going to do to them
yeah what were we going to do sell all
their women into slavery
were they going to kill them all after
the [ __ ] war you know that's what i
mean unconditional that could be any
number of horrifying things right right
but that's the way war was you know you
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up [ __ ] the
carthage
burn the city down kill all the people
sell the children as slaves and dog meat
sow the fields with salt never again was
there a carthage
that was it was genocide
that's the way wars always were up until
recently yeah which like i said i'm i'm
okay with that being in the past to be
honest it's temporary it'll go back to
that
well it might but i'm kind of hoping
only the western civilization stopped
that other civilizations have no problem
with the way it was if china goes to war
it'll be just like the old-fashioned
[ __ ] they're going to kill every [ __ ]
one of you
they got concentration camps filled with
uyghurs right now
they don't give a [ __ ]
if you're their enemy from their point
of view you deserve to die
your civilization deserves to be
extinguished that's the thinking that's
the way this was so it makes more sense
when you look at it through that eye
through that viewpoint
like i said i will say though that even
from the beginning because this
unit 731
wasn't
you know wasn't found until a little bit
later but the preamble for it
that goes back to like 1932 and the guy
that started it
was absolutely 100 aware that he was one
he was not supposed to be doing this and
two he knew if he got caught he would be
in like a really lot of trouble because
even from the beginning he made like
everybody that worked there they had to
take like fake names and it's like
everything had you know innocuous
sounding names so nobody would know what
they were doing so
the it you know it was formed
knowing that it they weren't supposed to
be doing it
so it was very very deliberate you know
what i'm saying yeah
i kind of need another drink
you know okay what the hell's going on
with that computer it's a oh it's uh
yeah it's just kind of like the screen
went blue and it was like something went
wrong we need to like restart your [ __ ]
i was like uh okay i don't know how long
it'll take so now it like turned all
purple but uh but yeah so okay so let's
talk about unit 731 like i said that's
the one that's like the most famous but
it's not the only one i'll get into that
a little bit later
um so this was actually a secret unit
of the uh and i'm sure i'm gonna butcher
like all these asian names so forgive me
in advance
uh the quantum army who was based in
manchuria this is well like a secret
unit of that now
see this is what i'm saying about them
giving it innocuous names
the name of this unit and the all of the
units like kind of under this purview
were the epidemic prevention and water
supply department that's what they
called it
um
and it was supposed to be
like a research center that was looking
into like you know disease prevention
like how do we keep you know diseases
from spreading among the army and [ __ ]
like that and how to keep the water
clean blah blah that's what they said
that their stated mission was
however
um their whole thing was
looking into
developing biological weapons now in
case you guys don't know biological
weapons
had been uh pretty much uh you know i
believe it was geneva like 1925 right
they said you weren't allowed to
use biological weapons um
so but as soon as the dude that started
this whole thing uh whose name was uh
ishishiro as soon as he heard that in
1925 he was kind of like yeah we
probably should start working on some
biological weapons now that geneva
convention has like made it illegal uh
because we might need those you know you
never know
so yeah basically he started uh doing
that
now the idea of the geneva protocol
rather not geneva convention the whole
reason why you make a biological weapon
is that you can attack your enemy with a
biological weapon and it's deniable you
could say i didn't do that
nature nature did that i didn't do that
so never forget that
never forget that the reason for bio
biological weapons is to hide the attack
yeah because you can just say that i
didn't do that yeah just a germ got in
the water like it was just a disease
spreading or whatever
sure
uh so yeah so ishii shiro
he had actually uh done field study for
two years um in the us and in europe in
our research facilities
so like i said as soon as he heard
uh you know at the geneva protocol in
1925
that biological weapons were not allowed
um at least you weren't allowed to use
them on urban populations i think that
was the wording as soon as he heard that
he's like yeah we need to start like
setting up some [ __ ] to develop some
uh but he knew that it was uh not
allowed and he knew that he would get in
trouble so he was like okay well we're
gonna establish all these units under
these like euphemisms
and then we're gonna start like uh
working on it so it's gonna be like
super top secret
so
there there was a thing called the
epidemic prevention research laboratory
um and he set that up you know not to
like in the early 1930s
now
the thinking even from the very
beginning the so this wasn't even a
thing
that
developed
you know what i mean because sometimes
like [ __ ] happens where it's kind of
like well we started out doing this
research on
weapons or whatever and then it like it
just
devolved into oh and by the way we're
blowing up babies
this seems like even from the very
beginning
um
that ishii was kind of like
okay well we're going to be using these
biological weapons on humans therefore
we need to test them on humans like that
seemed to be something that he was
pretty adamant about from the start
right
um and he wanted to kind of like set it
up as quickly as he could set it up
so
at this point so japan had been
occupying northeastern china
and
1932 there was uh like i guess it was
like a puppet state uh called me and i'm
sure i'm gonna pronounce this wrong
manchu manchukuo i guess
yeah so they set that up in 1932.
now
this was kind of like since this was
japanese occupied they're like okay well
we want a trial run of this you know
research unit that we want to set up so
we're going to set up one here and see
if we can like get away with it
essentially
so they set up something called the togo
unit
and um they've set this up in a village
whose name i'm not even gonna attempt to
pronounce
uh they set that up in 1933.
again this was a secret unit and the guy
that was running it was like the vice
chief of staff of the quantum army
and as i said this was kind of set up as
like a trial run to see if they could
get away with it to see if they could do
stuff without anybody like [ __ ] with
them and see if the experiments were
going to produce anything
that they could use
um all of the doctors at this particular
facility were military doctors uh as i
mentioned earlier they all took uh false
names because they knew that they would
get in trouble otherwise
um and there were about 10 doctors
working there like military doctors and
there was about a another 100 like staff
members like of various other in various
other capacities
so
that uh went pretty well
so in 1936 they decided they were going
to establish unit 731
uh so pretty much the first um
i guess the first reference to it was
like in a memo that came out in like
spring of 1936
and uh basically they're kind of like so
they set up unit 731 and then they also
set up two other ones
um
because okay so they set up this other
one these were also like biological
weapons ones the
the uh one of the other ones they set up
was called the quantum army military
horse epidemic prevention workshop
uh later on that would just be called
manchuria unit 100
and uh you know so that was that and
then they had a chemical weapons
development unit called the quantum army
technical testing department so they
basically said one of them was for
testing like how to prevent disease in
humans and the other one was how to
prevent disease in horses those were the
other two that they were setting up
aside from unit 731.
so emperor hirohito himself
gave approval for
setting up these
units and then they started like setting
up all the testing department
so
basically unit 731
it got you know the permission to move
forward
so they moved into like from the
unpronounceable village that it was in
to start with
uh they moved it to a hospital
in a place called harbin harbin i'm not
really sure how that's pronounced but
i'm sure i'm close enough so they moved
it there
now this was uh kind of temporary
because they were actually building like
a permanent one in uh ping phan which
was outside of the city
so
that was finished in 1939.
so after they moved over to that
facility
then they kind of like went they you
know they had the military doctors and
the earlier ones but then they kind of
started farming our like trying to get
in like private sector medical
researchers
that had worked in you know universities
or at other hospitals or whatever
so at this
point
when they first moved to their newly
built facility
um they got a bunch of like professors
from kyoto imperial university that was
like in 1938
the staff they had two
bacteriologists three pathologists
two physiologists
and a researcher specializing in animal
experimentations
a year later another group came um you
know with uh some more doctors and then
they had like other you know
staff as well
so
they also established i mean since the
you know the the war had been expanding
throughout china you know after the
after 1937 so then they started having
an other units established in any large
major chinese city like in the area like
near the war front or whatever
um they ended up calling these units
they also called them they were under
the auspices of epidemic prevention and
water supply department so they had like
unit 1855 that was in beijing uh unit
1644 that was in nanjing they had like a
bunch of other ones
so like i said 731 wasn't the only one
they kind of any major city that they
came to they would establish one in
there too so
they and honestly they called this the
ishii network like you know the guy that
founded it uh that's what they called it
because it was like a whole bunch of
different ones
so
by the time that all of these had been
set up
like you know right around 1939 or
whatever
uh they estimate
that the staff of all of these was over
10 000 people
so that's it's pretty big
now let's get into
like i mentioned earlier they're not
entirely sure how many people
died
um
at the hands of these
research facilities let's call them that
look at this [ __ ] what's she doing
she's laying on her back she's back
there going she knocked out phyllis
she fell asleep
oh my god that's so funny but she's like
so as i mentioned earlier
um they estimate they're not entirely
sure but they estimate somewhere between
200 000 and 580 000 people and like i
said a lot of these were
essentially civilians i mean they were
villagers uh prisoners of war
just basically because the the shitty
thing this is so scary
i mean basically when they would occupy
a city
um
and the researchers were kind of like
hey we need uh we need some experiment
subjects
go out and get some and they would just
go and get them yeah like we need that
we need x amount of
they called them maruta they called them
logs
because
well
well because the no the cover story was
that where these were set up that they
were lumber mills yeah so all of the
people
that they put in that they experimented
on they called them logs
so they would say something like how
many logs fell today like how many
people died or whatever isn't that
[ __ ] up now where was this location
again
well this one was in um what's it called
something manchu
no no no no no that was that was an
earlier thing that was an early thing
harbin harbinger where is harbin i'm not
entirely sure i'm not real familiar with
okay chinese geography this must be this
must be the japanese occupation
occupational army in china yeah okay
yeah these were all in china okay yeah
these were all in china yeah well they
were already gonna they were already
gonna mostly depopulate china they they
wanted that place
they needed they didn't get the natural
resource and the the the japanese
islands were getting kind of densely
populated
this had been going on for thousands of
years japan korea and china have were in
a [ __ ] basically a race war for
[ __ ] thousands of years they didn't
like each other at all
so clearly yeah so
the chinese the japanese saw the chinese
[ __ ] sub human barbarians
the chinese had been in a warlord period
up until this point still going on
chiang kai-shek was one of the warlords
one of the better ones which it was the
warlord period of china was kind of like
japan's feudal era with you know i mean
where they're all fighting
to [ __ ] secure a [ __ ] shogunate
type of deal yeah like that so the
japanese are kind of seeing them as
backwards like something from hundreds
of years ago
and they wanted to to depopulate that
area and get in there
same thing the germans wanted to do to
russia
when germany declared war on russia
there were no terms for russia the term
was die
it was a war of annihilation you know
yeah
and that's kind of in some ways what
japan was although
japan didn't say that to the rest of the
world they were saying they were coming
there as kind of like peacekeepers that
they were part of a chinese alliance but
that's not what they did when they got
in there
china was not a unified state so you
could get in there and you could [ __ ]
run amok
uh which they did yeah in this situation
so yeah so over the course of the whole
like over the span of the whole network
i guess uh they're estimating like i
said between 200 000 and 580 000 people
dying um as for just unit 731
they think maybe 3 000 and that was men
women and children just at that one unit
like that one hospital
now like i said you you had like the
military police essentially which i
think we're called the kempid kepitai
kempitai something like that
yeah um they would just like i said it
was basically like filling an order like
going to mcdonald's and ordering some
fries hey go get some people to
experiment on although like i said they
didn't call them people they they called
them logs or marita
which you know um so they think probably
like the vast majority of the people
killed were chinese like i said they
were just villagers that were that
happen to be in the occupied town
prisoners of war other people like that
people they didn't like whatever
there were also some russians in there
some mongolians some koreans
um
also probably um allegedly a handful of
americans handful of europeans maybe
some indians maybe some australians and
new zealanders who were
pows may have been experimented on also
like some people that
came out and told their stories later
said that there had been
people of other nationalities there but
it was largely chinese
so
yeah so basically it's kind of like
oh god this is so messed up it's like
[ __ ] now okay so the [ __ ] up thing
about this i mentioned them being called
logs because like i said one of the
cover stories was
that these places were lumber mills so
it almost started out as like a [ __ ]
sick joke that they just called the
people logs
and i guess it was just easier for
dehumanization purposes you weren't
calling them person
um
and uh also
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] too is that the some
of the experiments that they did
they actually did
um
publish like some of the results of
their experiments in actual like
scientific journals but of course they
didn't say they were experimenting on
humans because that's unethical and it
would have been published so they would
just like write it but they would say oh
we experimented on
manchurian monkeys or
long-tailed monkeys that's what they
would say and that's they wouldn't say
that they were human subjects
so
like i said it was kind of like mostly
chinese um and not all of them like i
said a lot of them are just like random
people they picked up but some of them
were criminals you know that they had
caught some of them were
you know really like anti-japanese you
know protesters or whatever political
prisoners um obviously mentally
handicapped homeless people because
they're of course gonna get picked on
because they're powerless
and
just anybody that was like acting in a
way that they didn't really like
uh but then there was also just random
ass they would just pick up babies
pregnant women whoever you know it was
just whoever they could get their hands
on pretty much
um you know so
it's kind of like oops there's like a
little there's a little bug here
so we're gonna talk about some of the
[ __ ] that they did to these [ __ ]
people it was just kind of like i read
this quote i think this was either on
the wikipedia page or on the um
there's a there's a site i think it's
just unit71.org or whatever it is and
it's just kind of like because there's a
museum there now
in that town that
they finally put one there i don't
remember when they put it there but
there is a museum there that's like
talks about the atrocities because for a
long time like japan wouldn't
um acknowledge it and even to this day
as far as because i watched a
documentary like a fairly recent
documentary and they were saying that
there is kind of like a um
like a
you know like a right-wing nationalist
type of uh group that is kind of like
holocaust deniers would be they're
basically like saying none of this ever
happened uh so they don't you know so
they don't want anybody talking about it
because they think it's all [ __ ]
which okay but yeah so there's that
whole uh thing too but so
here's this uh i read a quote by this
one guy who had actually seen what he
what is that a piece of pizza mama oh no
it's got black olives on it doesn't it
oh yeah
gritty
and pepperoni i made it from the other
day
i can't eat i'll just get heartburn and
i'll just have heartburn for the rest of
the show drinking on an empty stomach
that lemonade oh yeah
phil says what was the name of the
documentary um
[ __ ] it was just called unit 731
colon something
i can't remember it was just one of the
first ones that came up on youtube i
can't remember which one it was but it
was it was a really good one though it
kind of went like a lot into it but yeah
so like i said there is a museum there
now so they do actually acknowledge it
so there's this one guy that he wasn't
there but he did like see videos of some
of the experiments because apparently
they videotaped it because of course
they did
um and his quote was
uh some of the experiments had nothing
to do with advancing the capability of
germ warfare or of medicine
there is such a thing as professional
curiosity what would happen if we did
such and such
what medical purpose was served by
performing and studying beheadings not
at all that was just playing around
professional people too like to play
that's what he said yeah so base so it's
kind of like that's what i mean it's
like some of these experiments like i
said i'm not condoning them obviously
and you shouldn't like experiment on
[ __ ] humans that's [ __ ] up but
some of this stuff you could at least
see
you know the reasoning behind it it's
like oh well let's find out you know how
long it takes this disease to kill a
person like it's [ __ ] up to experiment
on a human like i said but you can see
why they would do it some of the stuff
they did here
not really sure
why they did it other than just sadism
you know and prisoners they had to get
rid of yeah
i mean it's just
[ __ ] man
yeah and justice for me says the
japanese call it chinese propaganda yeah
some some people do well there is like i
said just like
just like uh in the west there's
you know a small
contingent of holocaust deniers you have
the same kind of thing that happens in
japan you do have like a contingent of
unit 731 like that war atrocity like
deniers then you got a contingent of
bullshitters like the north korea north
koreans
they will take photographs
from these incidents
of like the
like japanese soldiers
executing or [ __ ] or beheading
chinese
civilians and then re-crop those photos
and say it's american soldiers killing
north koreans
yeah yeah then you're like looking at
that hand and that sword yo that's
definitely an american sword yes yeah
sure yeah americans are well known for
going around killing people
yeah with very curved swords yeah
that's a thing that a lot of us do
[Laughter]
well hey it's all about the cropping
it's all about the cropping
you never see the americans well like i
said [ __ ] man i could honestly i've been
doing photoshop so long i could probably
start my own whole propaganda network i
can make i can make a photograph of
whatever you want
i can make a photo just look at the
north korean american war crimes museum
you'll see some crazy [ __ ] in there that
you can see it
they'll give you tours through it
you won't see a single american soldier
just a bunch of dying uh asian people
and they're just like right out of the
dream
yeah where's the american dude it's the
american devil that killed this person
yeah right yeah
that's so funny
it's like gee it's funny they're never
in the photos
[Laughter]
they could have at least like
photoshopped her like drawn them in
there like a little smiley face man like
a little smiley face guy with like an
american flag shirt another universe
it's another reality north koreans
that'd be super funny if somebody tries
north koreans are a trip they're
in a parallel universe but they know
it's lies
yeah they know
they can't question it they'll get in
trouble
well yeah everyone it's just kind of one
of those things that's like well we've
all just decided that we're all going to
go along with them yeah exactly you know
they all know it's live
yeah so
uh let's talk about some of the
fun stuff they did to some of these poor
[ __ ] people that they just
randomly picked up
so
let's start with a good one vivisection
yeah which of you guys didn't know
that's basically uh they start
dissecting you while you're still alive
yeah no anesthesia with no anesthesia
uh basically the reasoning behind them
doing this and they did a lot of this
was that because
what they were doing is that they would
deliberately
infect a lot of the people with diseases
like lots of different ones
and they were saying well we want to see
what the progress of the disease is
um while the patient is still alive so
we want to be able to like see the
progress of the disease like on their
organs yes
so you cut them open and like keep them
alive and like cut them open and like
watch the disease like ravaging their
organs
uh for
research purposes
that was kind of like so yeah so
basically they would
strap people to a table and cut them
open but like keep them alive
but but i mean if they died they'd just
be like oh well bring in the next log
that's what they would say or go get
some new ones
it's just like [ __ ] like i said like
ordering some [ __ ] fries
[ __ ] ugh
so gross
that's funny because
you've given them these diseases
you know it's going to kill them but for
some reason you want to watch the
process and somehow document it as if
that changes the fact
or
your knowledge of their death really
doesn't help it as a weapon it's just
funny how they do that's what i'm saying
well see that's why i'm saying that a
very small percentage of this
you could see where like scientifically
yeah that knowledge might be useful
i think like 80 90 of this stuff would
have not been useful in any context they
were just doing it because they were
[ __ ] up psychopaths
the only thing you need to know is how
long does it take to kill them
how long does it take before they become
incapacitated
then the next thing you'd want to know
is is there a cure
and then so they'd be getting people
sick seeing how long it takes before
they're incapacitated
and then you'd be working on a cure to
it
because you'd want to know how long is
it going to take for the enemy to come
up with a cure
something you're going to know yeah i
mean like i said i'm not condoning it i
don't think anybody should do it because
it's [ __ ] up i'm just saying that
in some of the cases you could see the
justification behind it quote unquote
but a lot of this [ __ ] i don't really
see any value in it and a lot of the
[ __ ] is like stuff that they already
knew
you also want to cure
you want to know the cure so when it
blows back on you you can cure your own
people of it
yeah because there's no sense in using a
weapon that will affect you also you
want just to affect them
i will say too that um
[Music]
between like the two hundred thousand
five hundred and eighty thousand people
that died um there were also they
estimate 1700 japanese
soldiers
that died when one of them one of their
own biological weapons uh kind of blow
back yeah it's and blow back on them
can't feel too bad about that gotta say
but
well it depends on how you look at it
there's a lot of nice guys in those
japanese units that were just innocent
[ __ ] fun that's what i mean it's kind
of like it's it's really hard i mean
i don't know well yeah the knee jerk
thing is to be like oh [ __ ] them because
they were doing it but everybody's an
individual and not everybody like agreed
with that [ __ ]
not everybody was in that unit they're
gonna be some sweet old [ __ ] farm kid
just going yeah yeah mama you know
writing back to his mom and some of them
might not have known what was going on
no they don't know so it's like you
can't that's that's why i kind of get
well you can't punish everybody because
like most of the people probably didn't
have anything to do with what was going
on or didn't really have any choice in
the matter or whatever we live in an age
of blanket moralism you know what i mean
where everybody goes well you're you're
the bad guy [ __ ] you
everybody thinks the other guy's the bad
guy everybody thinks they're the good
guy
the japanese guys all thought they were
the good guys
they didn't know these experiments were
going on well like i said i kind of feel
like most villains like think like
probably the most horrible people
everybody everybody you got good people
mixed up in this on all sides yeah okay
that's what i mean and it's like i know
i kind of make jokes about it's like oh
everyone sucks and stuff like that
obviously they don't most people are
fine or most people are good or just
indifferent or whatever most people
wouldn't do evil [ __ ] just right out the
box you know what i'm saying but
circumstances under certain
circumstances
here's another story
the allies find
one of the first concentration camps
okay
they're keeping the prisoners inside the
cap they're not releasing them
the orders are don't feed them the
reason why is because they could kill
them but guys were sneaking food across
anyway
they were also allied soldiers american
soldiers were giving these prisoners
knives and then they were killing capos
in there all right because they had
capos who had kind of pretended like
they were prisoners also they were
german prisoners who were
kind of like the wardens of these
basically ethnic russians and jewish
prisoners that are in the concentration
camp
american soldiers saw this camp
and only a couple miles away
there were some surrendered germans who
had surrendered out of the war right
knew nothing about that cap they went
and massacred those german prisoners
yes
had nothing to do with that camp didn't
even know it existed that's what i mean
it's like well i have i'm angry at this
and i don't have anybody to direct it at
like the people responsible aren't here
in front of me but i feel like the need
to blame somebody yeah and you're here
right and and those which is [ __ ] up
don't do it and those german soldiers
were just kind of regular guys and you
know what i mean teenage guys guys in
their early 20s who had surrendered
because they didn't believe in this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
so they got killed because some other
guys found a camp over there
that's what i mean that's why you can't
you can't blame can't blame everybody
for everybody for what so yeah because
you don't know like yeah you don't know
who knows what
yeah they might not know anything about
it or they might not agree with it and
they're just trying to keep their head
down so they don't get shot or whatever
luckily some american guys jumped in
there to stop a slaughter some of them
were saved
you know i mean because these were just
soldiers they're just german soldiers
they just happened to be on the other
side they knew nothing about those camps
well they were just they weren't the
ones that had set them up right you know
they knew nothing about them they
weren't over there i mean i get it i get
that you like oh we can't trust them
blah blah blah but it's like you can't
you know you can't punish them for the
war was rapidly coming to an end right
and they were just going to go home they
were they were sick of the [ __ ]
yeah that's right like i said that's why
it's hard because you can't
you can't blame an entire country for
like what the government is doing for
example because a lot of people probably
don't agree with they don't agree with
it and they just get drafted those guys
were all drafted and they didn't they
didn't have choice
so
when you're a profession have the
background of a professional soldier you
have to understand that you're dealing
with systems
not in i was in a system that it was
doing [ __ ] i didn't know about
why would they hold me accountable for
something it happened somewhere else
that i wouldn't agree with and they were
doing it because some
[ __ ] in behind a desk somewhere
ordered it to be to happen yeah that you
didn't even know that i didn't know that
guy i don't even know that it happened
so it's a war between systems you can't
let that [ __ ] be personal
you know yeah the other individuals in
the in in the enemy army are not really
your enemy it's their chain of command
is the enemy
yeah they're just kind of doing what
they're the lackeys i mean you know no
they'll fight
but when they've given up they've
surrendered that's it they're they're
out of the fight
yeah i thought that was the whole point
i mean i thought we had all agreed that
like you surrendered to the others like
just don't [ __ ] with them anymore they
surrendered right that's the rules their
their their their authorities are their
chain of command was committing war
crimes they surrendered to you so what
do you do you're going to get even with
them by committing a war crime
by mass yeah that makes you as bad as
you're exact
that makes you as bad as them yep
it's like don't do that be the better
person yeah to be the better person
grant there's hammer ass uh question for
tom when the chinese invade the u.s
sometime in the future will they be
conducting nasty experiments on america
no the americans will be long be gone
that general what came out and said
that they had enough they had enough
biological weapons they could unleash on
the united states to totally depopulate
it and they can walk in here not a shot
fired
and they run to the bathroom
china has biological weapons
and uh no that's that's part of their
their war strategy if they wanted this
place
which i don't think they really do they
have
already a lot of land
the more land you have
the harder it is to keep control of over
and i think the chinese are happy
in on the chinese mainland
um
but they threatened that that general
openly threatened in a newspaper there
that
they would hit the united states with
bioweapons and totally
empty it out and they could walk they
could just walk in here just totally
unopposed that's their idea
is it possible
yeah
yeah if you're willing to kill everybody
and to just [ __ ] straight up do a
genocide
and the system you work for is all for
it and then yeah you could do it
the technology's there don't the what
what doctor strange love says but the
will you must have the ville to do it
and um
the chinese are at a stage of
development where they're just starting
to taste power they have the will i
think
we have to say
they would only do it if there would be
if if they knew there would be no
repercussions
and
this is a time where i don't think there
would be any repercussions if they were
to do that if a bunch of people started
dying around here
they would just think it was covet
they wouldn't think it was a chinese
biotech might be one of the same who
knows but
yeah
if i was a chinese general
now would be a good time
when the united states is weak and
divided
yeah
good thinking granters i don't know they
really want this place that's what i was
thinking i don't really
i don't think they really want this
place because i really think they want
this they've been on the chinese
mainland for [ __ ] 6 000 years it's
like it's so far [ __ ] and um
if they were to spread out have less
population density wouldn't be able to
control their people as effectively they
have problems controlling their people
on the chinese mainland to a certain
extent they have
little rebellions and riots all the time
um they're trying to man up right now
they're going into a war posture over
taiwan
that i think that's all they want i
think they just want taiwan
i think they're helping the
destabilization of the united states
just
just to make sure we're not strong
enough to defend taiwan i think that's
the idea
okay go ahead
all right so yes we were talking about
vivisection like i said fun
um also another thing they would do is
they would
they wanted to study blood loss like i
said this sounds like pretty bullshitty
this this is just like you want to do
some serial killer [ __ ] and getting away
with it that's what i'm saying
they want to study blood loss so they're
like hey
let's take these prisoners or logs and
start cutting their limbs off
and
maybe
just for funsies
let's cut them off and like attach like
they're switched their arms around
or putting switch their arms around or
it's like switch their legs around like
they would do [ __ ] like that on the same
person or between guys oh i'm not really
sure okay i'm not really sure probably
on the same person while they're still
strapped on the table hey what what
would happen if we put their arms on
backwards wouldn't that be funny that's
what i just kind of feel like that was
yeah
that yeah somebody said earlier like
earlier on and i i didn't read it and i
meant to but it's like they said the the
atrocities in here sound like something
an edge lord would come up with it is
it's just kind of like that's why i
think that they weren't they knew full
well that they weren't like doing
experiments they were just doing [ __ ]
up [ __ ] because they could do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] because they could get away with it
yeah um some people have said that you
know the japanese were not as
professional as the germans and stuff
um but you're you're so you're you're
assuming that the germans were
professional there was a lot of um
uh uh what do you call it
the german system
had a lot of redundancy to it and it was
very compartmentalized it wasted a lot
of [ __ ] resources and it did it did
crazy [ __ ] too it was a series of
fiefdoms
and some of it was about grift getting
state money getting getting government
money for a project so you could buy a
house so the japanese kind of did the
same thing they had some secret weapon
programs that were just as good as the
germans
um
and that's what you're seeing here
you're seeing basically
somebody abusing their fiefdom they got
a bunch of money they got a bunch of
power from the from the japanese
government and now they're just running
around having fun and now they can just
yeah that's kind of the that i know
that's [ __ ] up but that's kind of the
impression that i got like the more that
i read about this and that makes it even
more horrifying because it's like
the fact that they could just be so
cavalier right and then they're writing
up so they're probably writing up
sophisticated reports and then they did
to the government to their government to
to assure further funding
well like i said they even i think you
were in the other room but i said some
of them like some of the doctors and
stuff that were working there they even
like published papers like in
peer-reviewed journals but of course
they didn't say they were operating on
humans they said it was monkeys yeah but
they but they totally like so
in a way they were like ashamed of it
because they knew they didn't want to
get out but they were kind of like
having fun with it too and that is like
really really disturbing well a lot of
times they had to like hide it because
they were yeah they were top secret um
yeah they were already given they were
already given the orders that this isn't
happening this is a top secret program
so you can't say anything about human
experimentation or anything it's like
yeah oh yeah okay monkeys then yeah
monkeys i mean i kind of feel like 99.99
of people in the world other than like
psychopaths um you say human
experimentations everyone's like nah bro
yeah no
you know what i mean well in this in
this situation for the japanese area
humans are [ __ ] cheaper than monkeys
from their point of view getting chinese
people just is cheaper yeah that's what
i
mean
in chinese and we hate them so yeah
we're going to kill them anyway let's
use those
yep they're just logs yeah
that's so messed up like i said this is
happening in there from what they
believe is the apocalypse
they're thinking it's do or do or die
we got to get this done or we're all
going to die
that was part of the ultra nationalism
japanese ultra nationalist there was
some truth to it but they were
overreacting too much
you think yeah yeah well
their thinking was is that their
industries were expanding by leaps and
bounds and there and and the the chinese
homeland islands were going to run out
of natural resources so they had to have
china or they would all be poppers and
that japan would become weak and it
would vanish
and so they started [ __ ] around on
the mainland of china and america got
pissed and we put an oil embargo on him
which put him under so much stress it
was a do or die situation we have to
fight and defeat america or we die
so that's
in a way you could say america [ __ ]
tightening its [ __ ] grasp on it
helped kick this war off a lot
although they were going to probably do
that to china anyway so it probably
didn't make a difference it just speeded
up a process that was going to happen
anyway
and justice for me says uh reminiscent
of your girl next door review yeah uh
torturing someone and never even thinks
it's standard operating procedure
yeah that's i think that's what kind of
bothers me is i kind of feel like
as much as i think that most people are
you know marginally okay most people
wouldn't do [ __ ] like this right out of
the box
but under certain circumstances if you
were
kind of dead into it over a time or if
you were given like a justification
maybe more people than you think of
would do this kind of [ __ ] and i'm not
saying everybody would because they've
done experiments like this you know
where people thought they were torturing
people or whatever and you know about
half people are like yeah no i'm not
doing that
but some people
well the german people did the germans
went out of their way to select the
right man for the right job they knew
who they did they knew about psychology
they knew who was a sociopath or a
psychopath and they would put they would
give them these jobs
and then everybody under them i feel
like you would want to put people that
would just like do [ __ ] without
questioning it they were from shady
backgrounds a lot of those people yeah a
lot of those people were sent to places
like this is kind of like punishment
because they did something [ __ ] up
somewhere else
they say okay you're gonna go to this
this unit or you go to prison
because how could you just stand there
and watch someone alive
get their arms cut off
and like how could you
no i don't know not be like stop it like
you know what i mean it's like please
don't do that you know what i mean i
don't understand how you could like not
i don't know if that's the japanese the
first time you saw that i don't know if
this
if that was the japanese selection
process for places like this
but it was the selection process more or
less that the germans had and the
germans and the japanese
did communicate quite a bit they uh
modeled
japan kind of modeled a lot of its stuff
a lot of itself after which what germany
was doing
when it came to uh high-tech
weapons
so they probably figured they probably
had kind of a german model
they knew who was a psycho or a mad
scientist and they went to these kind of
units dudes who got in trouble
had a choice they either go to this unit
and work or they go to jail for
something that they did somewhere else
that might have been yeah so they might
have been like drawing from kind of like
the criminal underwear yeah the germans
definitely did the germans had an entire
well that explained a lot yeah the
germans had an entire [ __ ] ss i think
what was it called the 30 the 30 the
34th or the 44th
the 34th panzer ss i think is what it
was
and they were all taken from prison and
those are the ones that did a lot of
those damn war crimes that the russians
were pissed off at
you know burning down killing children
with bayonets in the orphanages that
they would capture and [ __ ] raping
bunches of women and setting putting
everybody in the barn and setting it on
fire that was that one ss division taken
out of them
there's a documentary about that yeah
not too long ago and and the the the
commander of that unit was a pedo he was
ta he was on his way to prison you
either [ __ ]
raping underage girls and he either and
he had been to prison for it already so
he was going back to prison so he was
already he was a serial sex offender
yeah okay so um so we're already like
not this is a person that
has
they used them for eternal security a
lot kind of like solder car terror
troops out of dune to keep people in
line inside occupied territory
but as the as the reich started to
collapse they actually fought well
against the russians and died most of
them died fighting the russians
and they weren't soldiers they were
criminals that were trained as soldiers
they worked out pretty good
which you would think that you couldn't
control those dudes but as long as you
set them to an enemy area no they did
well
well i kind of feel like most you want
them around your people well most of the
time people that have those kinds of
like criminal mindsets
like i said if you give them license to
do whatever they want like just hey
don't do it to us just do it to those to
the enemy people over there
then yeah you'll probably get like a
it's like you're not going to get in
trouble the other ss generals were
uncomfortable around them they didn't
want to even be associated with them
they're like get keep those
[ __ ] deployed far from us we
don't want to be around i mean in a way
if you think about it it's actually like
a pretty smart tactical move yeah well
instead of sending a prison you [ __ ]
send them into combat and then you send
them on difficult messages and then
missions and then they all died anyway
they died fighting the rights
so it's kind of like a win-win
they knew what they were doing
well like i said now that now that you
say that it makes total sense yeah
because like i said it's a good way to
get rid of get rid of your criminals one
way or the other
and you can also like [ __ ] up your some
of them did survive and they kind of
like had a [ __ ] some heroic swagger
to him but you know we're talking about
a few handfuls of them survived
yeah survive the war i mean but you know
they're all dead now i'm sure
i hope so they're all dead
too bad there's not a hell
because they'd probably all be we don't
know exactly what those dudes who
survived who they were they were all
individuals you know what i mean
it might have been a carjackers and [ __ ]
like that you don't know who survived
first power 100 said this reminds me of
the iceman richard kuklinski episode
where it was mentioned that under the
right circumstances he would make a damn
good soldier that's what i'm saying it's
just kind of like
somebody like kuklinski like i said he's
kind of an interesting dude because
he was just doing [ __ ] for a job which
in a way sounds worse but
i don't know i don't know if it is we'll
just do the [ __ ] for the job that's what
i mean so i i don't know like it's still
bad but it's like i don't know if it's
worse than somebody that just does it
like for funsies or because they get off
on it
i kind of feel like that's worse
every mercenary professional soldier
gets off on it or they wouldn't be doing
it
i like this
i know but i mean
i don't know but there but there's like
it's a difference of degree is what i'm
saying
yeah you know i'm saying every
everything's on a on a spectrum
so there's just what mission will you
take and what will you not take
what side do you want to fight on
you know
do you want to fight for the underdog or
do you want to oppress the do you want
to oppress the underdog
that's not
always it's always the first thing at
least at least in my situation what
that's the underdog no that that was the
second thing you said what if the
underdogs are bad though
well that depends doesn't it yeah well
everything's a point of view well yeah
uh yeah so okay so yeah icemaker let's
go okay so what were you talking about
okay so
yeah so they're cutting off limbs while
the people are still alive switching
them around like i said just for shits
and giggles i guess it's [ __ ] up
uh also sometimes
they would
also while the prisoners were still
alive they would take their stomachs out
and then hook up their esophagus right
to their intestines
like i said what possible
medical reason could you have for doing
that [ __ ] with them that's what i
mean there's no reason for doing that
really
you're just doing it because you're
having a good time yeah either they
wanted to know a person could live
without a stomach
but no you
this almost seems like every day yeah
it just kind of like they turned up to
work and it's like i feel like the the
people at the top like the top echelon
like i said we're probably a bunch of
psychos and it's like oh i love my job
i'm gonna turn up it today and it's like
what can we do today to just like i
wonder if a person could live without a
stomach no let's let's try that out
i just kind of feel like this reason
yeah i'm just kind of like
can we not i mean can we just like um
we can just extrapolate did they even
record how long it took for a person to
die without their their stomach oh i
don't know probably
but i i just kind of feel like it was
this whole thing where they were just
like they were just doing it because it
entertained them yeah there's no
possible medical reason you can have the
opportunity it's like you have a stomach
for a reason uh you evolved that for a
reason
um why would you want to take someone's
stomach away just
because you wanted to oh we're just
curious to see maybe they wanted to know
just in case they wanted to know my
stomach ever falls out maybe they wonder
this what happens if you've got stomach
cancer can you just take the stomach out
can you keep the person alive
i'm sure that's how they justify what
they just said yeah holy crap but they
would like take out they would like take
out little pieces of other organs let's
take out part of their brain let's take
out one of their lungs let's take out
part of their liver let's see what
happens yeah they did this [ __ ] why they
were alive too while they were awake
yeah yeah they're awake no anesthesia
yeah
what pot
it's just it's just sadism that's all it
is at this point it's just sadism yeah
even the germans didn't do that kind of
[ __ ] that's what i mean this is [ __ ]
up
so yeah so like i said the whole point
of unit 731 or so they said was to
develop biological weapons
so that was kind of like a big part
other than all the vivisection and stuff
which apparently they just did for fun
um
the biological warfare [ __ ] they did a
lot of stuff with that as well
now they actually ended up breeding like
a
a strain of plague infested fleas
in their labs this was unit 731 and one
of the other units which was unit 1644
and they had dropped those
on uh with planes on a couple of chinese
cities in the early 1940s
now
this ended up killing
uh
many many many thousand people
uh because they
made these
they these fleas had bubonic plague so
it was it was effective
yeah
yeah it killed the boy it makes you
wonder it had the body count been bigger
and faster and they just dropped fire on
them
that's what i mean that's why it seems
like this kind of [ __ ] was just like
it's just like creative ways to be a
monster
only thing that you could say is that it
might have been more deniable that you
could use it and then say no we didn't
attack you
that's the only like a stealth stealth
it was it was fleeting the only way
fleas you guys are just dirty and you
have fleas and the fleas gave you yeah
we didn't have yeah we didn't have
anything those fleas that was the only
good thing that that would be used for
they essentially dropped like ceramic
bombs full of flames bubonic plague
carrying fleas yeah on various uh
villages in china and killed tens of
thousands of people with bubonic plague
and honestly like a couple of the
documentaries i saw
um there were people still alive many
years later that still had
like wounds on their legs that like that
wouldn't heal yeah like that still had
like leftover [ __ ] like you know older
people from that time that still had
wounds that hadn't healed in like
decades
from that era
yeah you know what i mean because of all
the [ __ ] diseases they dropped on
them americans proved though later on on
the japanese themselves that that's not
the way to go the way to go is [ __ ]
white phosphorus
just drop
white phosphorus that was one of the
ones they that's
that was one of the ones they did too
yeah
firebombing of [ __ ] tokyo man i
killed millions and millions just in a
night more than that damn atomic bomb
that hiroshima bomb was nothing
compared to the firebombing of tokyo it
took more planes it took longer
burned all [ __ ] tokyo to down you
guys can look up online maybe you can
drop it in the comment section i forgot
how many millions but killed millions
millions of them just on that one night
just with [ __ ]
about i think it was i think it was fat
white phosphorus the white phosphorus is
gelled gasoline
that probably wouldn't have worked in
europe because it was those are stone
buildings
but
asian buildings at that time were all
[ __ ] wooden paper as soon as you got
that [ __ ] burning the whole thing had
burned
enough there was enough although they
did that to dresden and the fire storm
storm was enough to suck people into the
flames you know it was a 200 mile an
hour wind sucking people into the
[ __ ] flames that was about as bad as
an atomic bomb
so you can do it to a stone city
you just need enough
it's just got to get it hot enough
and you can get a city hot if you got
enough airplanes
there's another time it was a [ __ ]
another time the thinking was very
different back then
and like i said even if i had a time
machine yeah not going back there no
thank you even the dudes dropping the
bombs were horrified
of the firebombing of tokyo as well they
should have been they said they could
just smell it and then in their minds
they could hear everybody screaming down
in there
as they were running those bombing runs
yeah it's [ __ ] up yeah grampur's
hammer said the u.s has a history of
this stuff too tuskegee yeah i actually
would like to do a show about that one
of these days yeah uh the tuskegee
experiments look that up if you want to
be also horrified at some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that we did because uh
yeah solutions we're not much better
to be honest with you well i mean no
we're better
but not not the same numbers not the
same viciousness yeah but it was also
more piece meal it would kind of come
and go but we've done similar kind of
things but on a smaller smaller scale
and a lot of times local governments or
or corporations were involved in it it
wasn't so much what the american people
were doing
it was just
wacko [ __ ] oligarchs and [ __ ] we're
doing weird [ __ ] that goes back to the
damn
bubonic plague blankets given to the
indians if you look into the details
a lot of that was railroads doing that
well yeah it's like railroads why are
all these people dying oh my goodness
how convenient now we can buy all this
land yeah we wanted to put our like
railroad across yeah the american people
the american government had nothing to
do with it they didn't know about it
the british did it too
yeah but uh yeah
the the railroad people forgot how
powerful the people worried about how
powerful big tech is they're [ __ ]
real powerful
but there was a time where the railroad
had their own private armies their own
private court system that would [ __ ]
sentence employees to death
well yeah
look what happened to a lot of people
that like wanted to like strike for
better [ __ ] uh you know wages and
[ __ ] like that they just like mowed them
down yeah and they got done about it
they found along in remote places on
these old abandoned railroads
mass graves filled with [ __ ] irish
and chinese dead from bullet wounds
buried up and no record of what happened
it could have only been a labor uprising
and then they were [ __ ] mowed down by
railroad mercenaries and then just
buried imagine wanted to get fairly paid
for your labor yeah well it might have
not been paid it might have been food it
might have been it was something
happened
something happened there's no record and
we're talking like a couple hundred of
them we're not talking like two or three
dudes like a couple hundred
so [ __ ] like this half [ __ ] like this
[ __ ] had enough money you have enough
money you can get away with pretty much
pretty much anything you want pretty
much anything and that's been true all
throughout history and it is still true
nowadays yeah i think big threat i think
big tech is the threat i just do
it's a money it's it's it's a monopoly
but this isn't the first one
when it came to physical threat i would
think that the railroads were probably
the biggest at one time that's what i'm
saying it's like a lot of people like i
think
if you have a lot of money you can still
get away with [ __ ] nowadays but i think
it's slightly less bad than it used to
be the railroads used
back then they i mean if you yeah if you
understand that whole town that's what i
mean you could just operate with
impunity and everybody like okay
no one would do anything yeah they there
was a time where towns pissed off the
railroad the railroad says okay [ __ ] it
we're not stopping here anymore
and then that town is gone because the
railroad wouldn't stop there yeah all
those people's like
they all had to leave or they died or
whatever they left i think
yeah i mean that's a lot of power so
like i said that's why i don't really
complain about stuff nowadays because
i'm like i look back at net back then
i'm like yeah stuff sucks now but you
have you have recourse you have a way to
stop yeah i would not have wanted to
live back then and at least now you know
you have access to information you know
what's that back then they didn't even
know no they didn't know what's going on
they know what's going on they didn't
have an internet they didn't have and
like i said papers were all yeah they
didn't have any yeah they didn't have
any recourse yeah um i mean at least
nowadays you have different channels
that you can like
you know go through
sourced information i mean it might not
still might not work out for you and it
probably won't but it's better than it
used to be yeah a lot better yeah you
know
and really has nothing to do with
governments or laws or anything what it
is is it's better now because the
average person has access to technology
that that past generations could have
only dreamed of right technology gives
you power not really laws or governments
well i mean nowadays everybody that can
afford an internet connection has
essentially their own printing press
yeah 3d printers [ __ ]
crowdsourced information internet
[ __ ] um just guns uh the
the ability to get knowledge to grow
food uh it's just
cryptocurrencies
there's just so many ways around that's
what i mean see this is why this is what
what i was telling you earlier this is
what i'll [ __ ] about stuff nowadays
cause i'm like look i've read a lot
about like the way [ __ ] was back then i
would not go back to that no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way you can find out anything
you need to know in seconds nowadays
you could be free back then though too
you could get a horse and ride out and
[ __ ] live like jeremiah johnson but
the thing is only certain people can do
that
you know what i mean and only certain
people would be happy doing that
you can live in a town
and
in a suburban town
and have access
to
to everything now and it didn't used to
be that way
you could have something delivered to
your front [ __ ] door that's what i
mean everything's like easy now
and like i don't think that's bad no
great i mean in some ways like yeah
stuff shitty like yeah corporations are
too big they have too much power but
that's always been the case yeah
um you know ever since the industrial
revolution and if you look at history
it tends to where their [ __ ] gets sorted
over time a lot of times they become
obsolete by something else that replaces
them
so
you can ride it out that's what i mean
none of those [ __ ] none of
those [ __ ] are king of the hill
for very long yeah that's what i mean
they're lucky to be king of hill for two
decades
usually it's less usually it's
10 years like i said i'm just gonna like
yeah carve out my own [ __ ] yeah with the
[ __ ] that i have a lot of the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] people up are platforms
and new platforms come online that's
what i mean that's why i don't worry
about it yeah that's don't worry about
it yeah
you know everyone was like everyone
probably flipped out about [ __ ]
myspace back in the old days nobody's
gone nobody's on myspace nowadays
youtube does [ __ ] up [ __ ] look at
odyssey
look at [ __ ] shoot there's options you
don't have to [ __ ] live on youtube
that's what i'm well that's what i mean
it's like that's why i don't get like
all the pissing and moaning it's like if
you don't like it just go
there's other places yeah you know what
i mean you can find [ __ ] you like people
are getting hit hip to it
same thing with [ __ ] crypto
give me matt it's gonna be [ __ ]
you're having countries now venice i
think what honduras i think says accepts
crypto you're gonna start seeing [ __ ]
bitcoin
which will get around bankers and banks
have for forever it goes all the way
back to [ __ ] going all back to
abraham lincoln he was worrying about
the pot he was warning people about the
powers of banks and banking cartels
and uh
they're panicking now
because they're slowly becoming obsolete
crypto and and electronic
currencies will replace
the big heavy power brokers of the past
well that's what i'm always saying
that's why i don't kind of like i don't
like to make any like predictions about
the feature and stuff because one i've
seen a lot of sci-fi and none of that
[ __ ] ever pans out the way they think
it's gonna pan out but also because
technology
um you know evolves in a way that not a
lot of people can predict and
we don't actually know how shit's gonna
turn out or what you know what the end
game of like a lot of stuff yeah because
there's like a lot of stuff that nobody
intended and it was just kind of like oh
this was a surprise how did this if you
look at the shining you know [ __ ] our
boy our boy put all these hits about you
know the federal reserve and [ __ ] you
know the upper classes and the banking
system the gold room and all that crap
i think it was norway it was norway or
denmark finland went uh one of the ones
one of those norwegian companies they
got pissed off at the banks
10 something almost 15 years ago they
said [ __ ] it they banned all banks no
banks they just have a damn app a
national bank that's an app on their
phone and that's their bank it's the
their country's bank which is that's
what our constitution says that congress
should print the money really should
just be an app it would put all those
banks
banking cartels out of business would
they get pissed yeah they'd get pissed
a lot of [ __ ] would go bad
but there should be a national option
your country should have its own bank
you don't need private banks not anymore
that can echo that's what i'm saying
it's like honestly i just kind of i like
the option of having
private banks but also if you want to do
the national and like i said that's kind
of where i'm at with like the health
care system i really wish
that the u.s had an option i guess it's
better than it used to be but
because you know with because i don't
have any health insurance i don't know
what you guys don't i haven't had
anything
[ __ ] designed [ __ ] you but it's like
it would be nice if you could have an
option for you know like uk has the nhs
it would be nice and the uk has nhs but
it also has private healthcare if you
want to if you know they have that
option you should have both
that's what i mean so that's why i think
that's better
um you know as far as i know most of
europe has that they have a national
system if you want to get on that you
could just pay taxes you pay into it and
it's fine if you want some other [ __ ]
that's it's private insurance you can
buy that too
because some states have that yeah but
florida states
laura doesn't have it but you know
it depends on the state
my health insurance plan is don't get
sick don't be sick
[Laughter]
go to the emergency room it has been for
the last
several years go to the emergency room i
haven't had health insurance since 2000
how much is how much is health insurance
a month i don't know depends i'm getting
older so it'll probably not get any
cheaper just saying although i'm like
i'm in fairly good health though
so okay let's get back to the show yeah
so like i said so okay so where was eyes
plague infected uh plague and place to
infested blah blah blah fleas with
bubonic plague so yeah there was a bunch
of that killed a bunch of people
um also another thing they would do
super fun um they go to nanking
and they started putting like typhoid
and paratyphoid
into like the water supply you know what
i mean like in all their wells and stuff
like that
uh
and
honestly the like the researchers were
super super jacked about this because
this turned out super well
putting typhoid into the wells they were
like ooh
they thought that was like super
effective that was like
that made them very happy this is so
[ __ ] up
so
uh as far as they know
there were about a dozen what they they
called these field trials
which you know
love that euphemistic language
they call them field trials that was
when they essentially either bombed
the area with
plague ridden bugs or
put
diseases into the water supply of
whatever
the city was
um so they think that there were at
least 11
cities in china attacked with biological
agents
um so like i said they estimate
that
at least one attack the city of changda
that was about 10 000
casualties there with the disease that
they uh dropped on there
also i think i brought this up earlier
uh killed 1700
japanese troops
because they
also drank the water i think this one
was cholera yeah that was like one
because like i said they they were
trying all kind of diseases they're like
okay what do we what are we gonna do
today let's do botulism today that'll be
fun
let's do let's do bubonic plague today
let's do cholera let's do smallpox why
not
we got all the diseases
let's put in somebody's water and see
what shakes out i just i just kind of
feel like that's
that's what they were doing they're
coming into work and did god this is so
[ __ ] [ __ ] up so yeah so they put
they either put stuff into the water
supply or they would put stuff in these
like ceramic encased
bombs essentially like a fl like a flea
bomb and they would drop it on the city
and like the fleas would bust out and
then they would like give people
diseases
and like thousands and thousands of
people a day
so you know
uh also another fun thing they would do
was that
they would um
drop
food and
clothing into
areas of china that were not presently
occupied by the japanese
uh which were also infested with disease
so you know that's also fun
uh they would also go they wanted that
personal touch i guess so they would
just go house to house
or down the street and give people like
poison candy
so you know like i said it's like a
[ __ ]
urban legend about halloween or some
kind of [ __ ] like that let's get it's
like put some razor blade in the candy
and like give himself what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ]
this is killing me
so uh i don't know if you guys knew this
but
uh because of uh as a result of all
these shenanigans japan thought hey you
know what we're gonna do
we're gonna put bubonic plague
in some bombs and we're gonna drop these
bombs
on san diego okay yeah
they were going to do that
uh in late september of 1945
but japan had surrendered like before
that
but they were totally gonna do it i know
what they were talking about they were
totally what they were gonna do is they
had a couple of submarines
that were wide enough to carry two
airplanes in them
weird but yeah they had aircraft carrier
submarines
and that's what they were going to do
they must put bio bombs thank you david
marines
and
unleash them planes
you can look that up it's pretty neat it
was a submarine front end of it would
open up there'd be there were sea planes
on there and they could ride out they're
on pontoons they were kind of like as
like a zero like a japanese zero
and they could fly out and drop some
bombs that's what they were gonna do
they were gonna take out the panama
canal with that [ __ ] yeah i think they
tried if i remember correctly they had
big plans yeah
the japanese got tied up though they
didn't come to pass obviously
yeah
they
they knew they couldn't beat us
not in the long run they thought that
they would if they uh
destroyed the pacific fleet at pearl
harbor that we would cut and run
hirohita says nah that's not what'll
happen you know because they will
[ __ ] fight back
it'll take them a few years
they might kind of lose for the first
two years but then while they're back
there in america building the new navy
two years later they'd come back here
and [ __ ] we'll fight him and we will
lose two years after that that's exactly
what happened
it's exactly what happened
our old navy and our old [ __ ]
marines didn't do well for the first two
years against the japanese
yeah but when the new [ __ ] was ready man
they could not adapt fast enough because
our planes were
far better than theirs that the new
generation that came out too it was far
better than theirs
the carriers and a lot of the ships and
[ __ ] and just the training and the
quality of the men were just a lot
better
two years after the war started we got
stronger as it went on they were getting
weaker
they just couldn't they didn't have the
industrial might to change
fast enough we just overwhelmed them
their planes were just [ __ ] sitting
ducks
after that new generation came out when
the corsair was out
the [ __ ] hellcat
i think it was a hellcat yeah hellcat
there's an aircraft carrier plane that
was it was through
through they couldn't deal with that
japanese plans just weren't good enough
not enough armor not enough guns
airplanes are flying tanks compared to
theirs but when the new planes came out
thank you david june if we died and went
to a matrix existence how would btk
survive without killing would they put
killers in a world where they can kill
anyone or torture by us i kind of feel
like they should take the serial killers
and just put them in their own little
virtual world
you know like grand theft auto you can
go in there and you can like kill people
with imp but they're not real people
they're just like
npcs
i don't know
a serial killer is mostly he's mostly
imagination imagination and fantasy
he may already be in a world like that
inside of his head well so put him in
one of those literally yeah i don't see
a problem with that
as long as he were to believe the
illusion he'd be happy probably put him
in the soup and like hook them up to the
[ __ ] i'm i'm cool with that it's part of
their sexual orientation
i'm cool with that yeah
although you know
most most people who've studied it
including syracuse themselves you know
when they hit adrenopause when they get
about 50 they slow down a lot they
become kind of like has-bends they don't
have the energy to go out and kill some
chick it just doesn't it's just not as
exciting like it was
so
you can't be a serial killer forever
even in heaven you should read um a
novella that i bought too long ago not
too long ago that i reviewed on my
channel called larry
and it's about like a jason style serial
killer who was doing [ __ ] in the 70s and
then now like he's really old and he
lives with his mom and [ __ ] yeah and but
he's like 65 but he's like man i need to
get back out there and like kill some
teenagers yeah oh my god it's so [ __ ]
funny
it's so [ __ ] funny yeah i reviewed it
not too long ago uh but yeah adam
millard wrote it he's a british writer
uh grand there's hammer said one could
argue that america is in conducting its
own sick experiment via 32-ounce
mountain dews and super-sized fries with
a bacon cheeseburger yeah
right i don't know i i kind of feel like
people want that but
are you okay pook i think she's asking
did she have her clothes on no i had to
put a collar on put her clothes on yes
she's going come on go outside okay
you'd be good though
don't you go far
pull pokey
yeah it's
you know that's the thing i don't know
if it's any kind of like
um
you know any kind of like conspiratorial
hey let's kill everybody with like
[ __ ] heart disease but
because the human body does crave fat
and sugar it just does it tastes good it
you know that that's just how we evolved
so i think all it is i don't think
anyone's just like has a plan to like
exterminate everybody i just kind of
think that well we just want to make
some money and humans really like fat
and sugar so
we're just gonna like put more of that
and it'll taste like really good so
everybody will buy it so i think that's
the only thing that's going on
but yeah so like i said they were going
to uh
japanese were gonna like drop some
plague on san diego but they never got
to fortunately because they surrendered
five weeks before their planned
[ __ ]
but uh
one thing they did do was that
in various chinese cities
they dropped a bunch of like i said
fleas with bubonic plague they also
dropped in a bunch of clothes and a
bunch of like just very supplies food
and stuff like that that had different
things
on it you know what i mean it had like
anthrax
or cholera or whatever
and this ended up killing almost half a
million chinese civilians so you know
uh there's so there's that whole thing
here's another thing they were doing too
was that
they were
testing or so they said they're like we
want to know
what would happen like i said
this is like them showing up at work and
being like what do you think would
happen if
we blew up a grenade like it's like
jackass
like i know it's like [ __ ] up to say
but it's like it's like [ __ ] jackass
they show up at work and they're just
kind of like what would happen if we
blew up a grenade
10 feet from a person or five feet from
a person let's let's find out how that
would happen go get me some logs and
we'll figure out
uh you know what [ __ ] will happen so
what they would do was they would bring
people in
and they would put the prisoners
in different like distances and
different positions away from where the
grenade explosion was going to be
because they wanted to see
how it would affect their body
you know they were measuring the
effective rate the blast radius of the
grenade yes also they would also test
their flamethrowers
the people so that's nice
uh so yeah so basically they would tie
their prisoners to
you know steaks
just tie into a steak
and they would either hit with a
flamethrower to see what would happen
uh i'm pretty sure what would happen in
that situation uh or they would just
blow up stuff at different distances
yeah from the people this looks like to
see what would happen this looks like
the stuff that the north koreans were
showing in the war crimes museum
i think that's what
it was that kind of [ __ ] there were
people tied up to stuff yeah yeah this
is this kind of [ __ ] they were doing
yeah uh and they their justification for
it was well when our guys get hit with
bombs and like hit with shrapnel and
stuff we want to see like what's the
best way to treat that or
you know
what happens like at different distances
with the with the fragmentation how good
is the fragmentation right right um so
that's kind of like what they were going
for or so they said like i said i think
this was no that's probably about right
here let me explain something to
somebody to you guys
in a grenade in a grenade
you've got a [ __ ] body that makes
shrapnel
in those days it was usually cast iron
and it was kind of like in a pineapple
pattern
and you put something like tnt
or some kind of plastic explosive
was that here
too hot
and then you set that off and what they
wanted is they wanted it to break up
break along the little lines in the in
in the pineapple pattern and throw out a
[ __ ] nice even distribution of
shrapnel that's that's never what
happened usually the bits broke in half
and only two pieces went flying
so grenades weren't very effective
especially those kind of grenades but
they weren't very effective
they were trying to figure out
the blast would kill a guy if it landed
close
but normally the frac the shrapnel
didn't usually the shackle missed you
from those old grenades
although
back in that grenades and those kind of
grenades favor they were usually thrown
into holes or thrown into the back of
[ __ ] fighting positions where it was
pressurized so the blast would kill you
because it was in an enclosed area
you